please rise for the chairman of than
District
Council
good evening
members of and offices of the council
and members of the press and public
I welcome you to this meeting of the
council if the fire alarm is activated
please vocate the office is via the
stairs either through the security doors
to my right or opposite lift in a foo
please do not use the
lift please assemble in Hy Square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it is deemed safe to
return to the chamber
I would advise you that if filming takes
place anybody in attendance of the
public generally may be that may have
their image
captured anybody film
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children
present does anyone attend to film the
meeting yes any m the any member of the
public who objects to to the possibility
of being filmed may wish to take the
opportunity to leave the
meeting
no any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any other item of business
where exempt or confidential information
is considered following the exclusion of
press and public from the
meetings when any with every would
everyone present please ensure their
mobile phone are turned to silent and
they are not used to make or receive
phone calls when the meeting is in pres
is in
progress apologies for
absence I have received apologies from
councelor cron Riki Paul Paul Mo are
there any other apologies for absence
chair and they are who do you want to go
to First coun councel Nichols and
councelor town and councel dwson he
that apologies from councelor
Pacman thank
you I move that the minutes of the
meeting of the council held on the 13th
of July
2023 be approved and signed as a correct
record would the Vice chair please
second seconded chair do members
agree thank
you item agenda three announcements I
have not been informed of any
announcements item agenda four DEC
Declarations of Interest are
Declarations of
Interest genda item five
petitions
the result of two petitions are being
reported to the council in accordance
with the council's petition Pro
protocol right so we got a agenda item
5A Jackie Baker's pedition
petition the council's response to the
petition is outlined in a report before
members the petition organizer Jun
Terell will present the
petition and has been signed by over
1500 people Mr Terell please please
approach the
microphone you have
three
good evening my name is June and along
with Ramsgate resident Christine we
launched a petition to raise awareness
surrounding the much needed improvements
at Jackie
Bakers we are both regular users of
Jackie bakers with Christine using the
site for her daily dog walks and myself
being part of the thanet Sunday football
league Jackie Bakers once home to a
football and hockey ASR Turf pitch and
cricket ground has seen a huge decline
in their facilities over the years
the cricet ground is no more and the
amount of vandalism caused to the astro
turf pitch has deemed it
unusable Jackie Bakers was gifted to the
people of Ramsgate by Dame Janet back in
1924 and we believe by making
improvements to the sites would be
beneficial not only to the local but
also to the sporting
communities after carrying out and
research we feel the improvements
required include extra bins located
around the site
both General and dog waste benches along
the main path and outer edges of the
football pitches a changing facility
complete with running hot water for
showers and toilets improved pitches for
footballers and a car
park we have taken further feedback from
the communities and feel that a sports
Pavilion with Cafe on site would be
widely welcomed by all that use Jackie
Bakers a larger play area with picnic
benches and a BMX skate park would would
make great use of one of the unused
pitches since launching the petition in
June we have seen improvements starting
to be made with the grass being
maintained to a better standard and new
goalposts being
provided we would like to like to
propose a weekly meeting at Jackie
bakers with open spaces and the head of
services where Christine and myself can
be kept informed of any progress and
also see that we the people of Ramsgate
are being listened
to we have a Community Action Group
where we will be advertising fundraising
ideas to enable us to continue to
contribute to in the improvements for
Jackie Bakers thank you for your
time thank you do members have any
comments Council open Council open
Council open
right thank you chair um thank you Mr
Chell for your uh petition um as you
obviously know we've met on SE several
occasions um since we were elected back
back in May um and as I've told you it
Jackie Bakers and the Redevelopment of
that land is a priority for
me and um I can assure you that along
with with myself and the senior officers
of this Council that is what we intend
to do you will be consulted at every
level and every Point uh when we are
making uh changes so the residents can
have their input as to what they would
like and how they would like us to
proceed thank you chair thank you
Council sorry councelor Davis coun D
councelor
Davis
thank you chair um I'd just like to
welcome this petition and to say as a
lifelong resident of Ramsgate how much
all residents support the uh maintenance
of Jackie Bakers as a counselor I'd like
to uh raise the fact that 106 monies
were allocated for the restoration of
these changing rooms in the Pavilion
several years ago which it appears have
not been used for the purposes they were
allocated for I'd therefore like to
recommend that this comes back also that
whilst we need this facility to be
brought back into good condition for the
benefit of the people we also need a
Lessons Learned uh report into why we've
ended up in this situation however I
totally support any moves to to protect
Jackie Bay because is one of the few
green spaces that hopefully the
covenants that protect it will be
respected by this Council thank you
thank you councelor Davis councelor Wing
thank you and thank you for bringing the
petition and I'm so glad it's actually
focused on our youth because very rarely
do we actually discuss things in here
which are about young people I think in
our own world we've benefited from the
investment that we've seen in in
Ellington Park and the addition of
toilets and a cafe has really really
given the whole place a real sense of
ownership and actually turned it into a
wonderful place for everybody to be so I
wish you well and you'll certainly have
our
support thank you
councilor thank you thank you very much
chair
um yes uh and just before this meeting a
democratic Service Officer came to see
if I'd had any technical problems
accessing the agenda today and I had to
tell them it was actually the other
councelor scobby so um we're going to
have this confusion I'm afraid um thank
you June for the petition we've been
working together over the last few
months and I think it is clear that for
uh the first time in a long time there's
going to be some action already taken
and more going to happen at Bak because
I think one of the things we need to
reflect on is how an asset that has the
potential to raise revenue for the
council has been allowed to go into such
a state of disrepair and that is not a
political point this is a point around
investment in Assets in Open Spaces
across
thanet but the the the challenge with
this asset and which is why I found it
very frustrating is there is the
opportunity for this in a time when the
council is struggling for money to
actually bring um money into the
council's coffers but also Al to allow
this space to be used uh councel Wing
referenced Ellington Park the
conversations um June Chris and I have
been having in recent months has been
about about how we can replicate that
model because one of the things that
Jackie Bakers has is huge amounts of
space to run events um and there's all
sorts of opportunities there um there's
two points I want to raise about this
petition um just more specifically
absolutely support the um the threat of
it and thanks to council
um for all the work that he's been doing
um there's a quirk of our petition
scheme here that if a petition gets
submitted at the wrong part of the year
it could actually be months until it's
actually heard and that's what's
happened here because I think members
may have noticed that the petition has
over 1500 signatures but it's going
through a process of less than 1500
signatures because it's the quickest way
to get action and one of the things I
think the council needs to consider is
how we can better adapt the petition
scheme in the future F because if it's
not working and we're having to find
different routes to get petitions in
front of members quickly then it needs
to be updated and I think what this
process has led is that this issue
should be being talked about cabinet in
the future at cabinet in the future and
it's not um and one of the things that
um and I think the leader may wish to
sort of explain himself but one of the
things we flagged up is that this
petition has come here it was too late
to change the process but I'm hoping
that this can be picked up by cabinet in
the future cuz there is an opportunity
to utilize that space and have something
for residents of all ofth to use so um
yeah I'll close my comments there but
thank you very much June for bringing
the
petition thank you councilor Kobe item
agenda
5B sry
ah well I don't know how many more
people were going to wish to speak on
this important item um chair um just to
say that um obviously I absolutely
endorse the aims of the petition and um
I think we all know the Administration
has been working towards delivering a
better solution for Jackie Bakers for
some time and I councilor Alburn and the
officers of credit for that and also the
new Ward counselors for Northwood who
are doing a great job and working with
the residents um we are going to deliver
for the residents of Northwood and more
importantly we're going to deliver for
all the residents of thanet and the
residents of Ramsgate so I would like um
a report to come back to Cabinet in due
course as it would have done if this
petition had gone through the scheme in
the normal way um explaining exactly
what's happening at Jackie Baker's so
that members can scrutinize um and I
give a commitment that that report will
come thank
you thank
you Vice chair would like to say a few
words thank you chair never have I been
so more grateful and privileged to
represent the Northwood Ward uh where
Jackie Bakers uh is uh I was brought up
there actually so it means quite a a
great deal to me but from the very first
meeting with Chris and June it was clear
that they were absolutely passionate
about their Community uh the facilities
at Jackie Bakers are miserable to say
the least the pitches and surrounding
areas are
Dreadful uh but with the will and
determination of such residents as Chris
and June uh they remain impressive more
than that motivational more than that
encouraging uh and this is what
cooperation looks like not only between
the counselors and the residents but it
seems to be cross party which is
brilliant uh this is what purposeful
engagement looks like and this is what
this counil can deliver starting with
Jackie
Bakers thank you
[Applause]
agenda item 5B northdown Park petition
the council's response to the petition
is outlined in the report before members
do members have any
comments councelor cup coun councelor
cup thank you chair um and I just wanted
to say uh how pleased I was to see uh
the supportive comments from the the
council and I think it's going to be
incredibly important and really good for
for the area um I would just also like
to say that I believe as much as this
will be fantastic for the local
community I do hope that necessary
funding will be allocated to it to
ensure not just the generations now but
future Generations can also root the
benefits of this thank you chair thank
you councelor
C item agenda six no no
more Council or yes thank you chair um I
thank councelor cup for his comments on
this and uh I think it's the same
um we do need to ensure in the current
circumstances that this country finds
itself in uh with the cost of living
crisis Etc that our parks and Open
Spaces are good enough for our residents
to use on on a daily basis and and
that's something I think that we all
want and uh we will all contribute
towards and um certainly for me I will
do all all that I can to uh ensure that
our parks and Open Spaces uh what our
residents want thank you chair thank you
Council councilor
Manis yeah um yeah I just wanted to say
as the uh one of the councilors for
Clifton Ville East that Northtown Park
is a really important green open space
in in the world um it's extremely
popular popular uh I was there yesterday
afternoon and there were probably 30 or
40 uh people using the uh the the the
play area but the the general area
around there reflects really badly on
the district and and on the council um
there is obviously neglect we do have
problems with antisocial behavior and
with the graffiti and the neglect that's
so obvious it it it's it it sends it
doesn't send a great message so I
welcome the council's response to this
and the idea that we will now be
refurbishing that Pavilion and I think
you know this is not the biggest asset
in thanet you know this isn't the Winter
Gardens um but all eyes will be on the
council to make sure that they do
deliver on this uh and get the Pavilion
and the surrounding area up to up to an
acceptable standard thank you thank you
councelor
maners
Duckworth councelor Duckworth Duckworth
yeah
councelor Duckworth please I wonder yes
as Cabinet member for property I was uh
very pleased to be shown around some of
the uh bits of North down Park that uh
people don't always see and there's a
lot of community work going as with
Jackie Bakers there's a lot of community
work going on so I'd like to thank uh Mr
Manar for sending in the
petition thank you do m H thank you
councelor
Dorth that's it that's it right item
agenda six questions from the press and
public there have been three questions
received from the from the press and
public in accordance with Council
procedure number 13 please note that
only the questionnaire respondent are
permitted to speak on the question could
the question questionnaire please only
state the name of the cabinet member to
whom they are questioned is to be put
and read out the exact wording of the
question that they submitted to the
council right so it's agenda item
6A question number one from the member
of the public regarding Arlington arcade
I would pleased to welcome Mr Lucy to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the
microphone he not here okay so we just
say not here so you'll get an answer in
writing right we just move on then can
just say that Mr El Lucy you'll get a
response in writing right so Mr Lucy
will get a response in
writing question number two from the
member of the public regarding
environmental agency pollution risk
alerts I am pleased to welcome Miss
Bailey to our meeting could you please
make your way to the
microphone
uh good evening uh my question is to
councelor
Auburn get my glasses
on um the environment agency pollution
risk alerts were issued at Viking Bay
over several days at the very height of
the
Season TDC put up warning notices and
the RN rnli flew red flags and ordered
people out of the sea over at tanoi
which which caused some alarm these
widely reported alerts had seriously
detrimental effect on local businesses
and on The Wider reputation of
broadstairs according to the EA website
pollution risk forecasts are made daily
based on measurements of rain tide time
sunlight and wind while they while the
sea water is only tested
weekly do we know the accuracy of these
forecasts are they ever confirmed by
retrospective testing
is this Arrangement between the T
between TDC and the environment agency
optional if it is optional what is the
rationale for signing up how long is the
agreement for and will it be
reviewed if it's not optional is there
anything that we can do to mitigate the
adverse effects on tourism and local
businesses thank
you thank you Miss Bailey I call upon
Council Auburn to
respond yeah thank you chair thank you
uh M Bailey for your
question um the objective of the
pollution risk
forecast uh system is to alert Beach
users to the potential for temporarily
increased bacteria levels in bathing
Waters the council displays notices to
advise that a prf that's the pollution
risk forecast is in place and this
enables bathers to avoid times or
location where the risk of pollution is
higher than normal and where health risk
from
bathing uh may be higher than the annual
classification
suggests it is important to note that
this is a vice against bathing this
season the rnli chose to fly a red flag
on Viking Bay in response to pollution
risk forecasts but they did not order
members of the public out of the
sea prfs are not Direct linked to storm
discharge notifications and are not
informed by a water quality test the
forast is generated by a model which
considers weather rainfall and tidal
conditions in order to make a prediction
High rainfall is known to affect water
quality on a temporary basis mainly as a
result of surface water uh runoff there
is no sampling undertaken to verify
pollution risk forecasts
uh however routine compliance samples
that indicate elevated bacteria levels
taken during short-term polition may be
excluded or
disregarded from the annual CL
clarifications uh provided that the
signs have been correctly displayed to
alert potential bers of the pr in place
in some circumstances the prf sorry it
was the prf not PR prf scheme can
therefore help to maintain the annual
bathing water classification the bathing
water classification is an important
quality qualifying criteria for blue
and season uh Seaside
Awards there were more prfs issued
during July and August this year than in
previous years this was directly linked
to the unseasonal weather at the time we
understand the concerns of local
businesses who may be impacted by poor
weather during the summer season and the
issuing of prfs officers have therefore
committed to engaging with the
environment agency over the winter
months to seek a review of how the prf
system is applied at Viking Bay and
consider the council's participation in
the scheme this may also include working
with the rnli to review the use of red
flags during the prf and consider other
ways of communicating the warning of
beach users thank you chair thank you
thank you Council
right question number three from the
member of the public regarding the local
plan I pleased to welcome Mrs Brown to
the meeting could you please make your
way to the
microphone good evening um my question
is for Council Everett and it's around
affordable housing infrastructure and
agreements if developers are asked to
fund the full cost of the north fet Link
Road and they say it is unviable to
provide the agreed affordable housing on
developments as set out in the local
plan there will be no benefit to the
residents of thanet gaining affordable
and social housing for the district was
the only advantage of allowing these
developments the mass development on
some of the very best agricultural land
in the country will be gone forever and
other and it will only be for the good
of other local authorities people
wishing to move to the area and private
investors local people will end up in a
worse situation with all the
infrastructure problems that entails and
my question is the current local plan is
written in a way that allows this to
happen does TDC propose to address this
in the local plan review to ensure this
is not the outcome thank
you thank you m
brown
where are
we I called upon the leader to respond
please thank you chair and thank you Mrs
BR for your
question K County Council are
progressing a bid under the department
for transport Main Road Network fund to
support the delivery of the north fet
link a key part of the inner circuit
proposed through the current local
plan the bid is now one of only two
priority schemes in Kent supported by
transport for the southeast and KCC have
received funding from the Department for
transport to develop the next scheme to
the next stage if the bid is successful
it would reduce those costs for the
relevant developers and enable more
contributions to a range of other
planning obligations including
affordable housing however if the bid is
not successful then the site developers
will have to fund the provision of the
scheme either way the council as the
local planning Authority is required to
meet the house housing needs for the
district as identified through the
government's housing standard method
this is based on population change in
the district over the plan period and is
designed to meet a range of existing and
future housing needs and this is the
primary benefit of new housing this
includes people already living in the
district including new households
forming for example young people leaving
the family home to set up their own home
and it also includes people who move
into the
district planning for housing for people
moving into the area is not only
required by government guidance it's
also important for local people because
it prevents them and particularly
younger people on Lower incomes from
being squeezed out of the local housing
market more affordable housing is the
first priority of this
Administration government guidance
supports the provision of affordable
housing and key infrastructure through
development contributions whether
Financial or incl on site however the
guidance is also clear that in setting
requirements for development
contributions local planning authorities
cannot impose a level of costs which
effectively renders development sites
unviable and prevents housing from being
delivered thus the local plan was itself
subject to a high level viability
appraisal and planning applications may
also be accompanied via viability
assessments that are independently
assessed and verified where viability
can be demonstrated to be an issue then
a decision has to be made about the
priority and balance of section 106
contributions to be
provided the clausing local pay policy s
sp23 that the requirement on housing
developments for 30% affordable housing
may be reduced if meeting the would
demonstrably make the proposed
development unviable is in line with
government guidance as was confirmed by
the local examination local plan
examination
inspectors in terms of the local plan
review we've been clear that we want to
we want the power to reject applications
on the grounds of protecting our
agricultural land that's a cross party
view as an
Administration we've also asked
government to help us in terms of the
existing local plan and this week I've
received some correspondence from the
Department of leveling up housing and
communities which seems to make clear
that the secretary of state will not do
that
I will be putting this correspondence in
the public domain in the next few days
so that residents can see for themselves
exactly what the government has to say
about it thank
you thank you
leader agenda item seven and questions
for the member of the
council 16 questions have been received
from members of the council please note
that the time allow for consideration of
questions from Members shall not exceed
30 minutes however I am happy to allow
the balance of the 30 minute public
questions session to to this one this
one allow the more questions to be
answered if we still cannot complete the
questions in the time and outstanding
questions will will receive a answer in
writing so we have 48 minutes 48 minutes
so we have 48
minutes question number one from a
member regarding use of Cate I call upon
councelor
Wing I think this question is to
councelor alurn I think we're always
it's always you I'm sorry uh how many
liters of weed killer containing
glyphosate were used by TDC in the last
four years 2019
2020 2021 and
2022 and where was this applied for
example around Parks playgrounds
buildings Etc and why are we still using
this out in our communities giving
residents little or no indication of its
use or indeed any choice to avoid if
it's being applied near them when the
international Agency for research on
cancer classes glyphosate as a probable
carcinogenic to humans and increasing
number of councils of of countries and
councils within the UK have banned
it in favor of alternative
methods I call upon councelor alurn to
respond thank you chair yeah thank you
councelor it wouldn't be the same
without a question from you at Council
um so to answer your question
approximately 90 liters of glyphosate
have been used by the council in each of
the last four 4
years legally enforceable conditions of
use are imposed on the way products can
be applied to ensure the public are not
exposed to levels of pesticides that
would harm health or have unacceptable
effects on the
environment application is via Spot
Treatment
only it is never sprayed openly and is
not used in playgrounds along the
seafront around trees in flower beds or
around shrubs and hedges if at this
point chair if I could just say that um
if you've seen anybody spraying or
whizzing or spray around as I have it's
Kent County Council and not thanet
District
Council herbicide containing glass oh
sorry I've just done that
bit um right ghate remains approved for
use in the UK until at least
2025 the health and safety executive
notes that the responsible use of
pesticides in immunity areas as part of
an integrated program of control can
help deliver sustainable benefits for
society these include management of
conservation areas invasive species and
flood
risks access to high quality sporting
facilities and safe public spaces for
example by preventing we growth on hard
surfaces creating trip hazards
industrial sites and transport
infrastructure now that's the end of
your the answer to your question but
what I can also advise you which you
don't know is that since we have been
elected we have been considering the use
of gly
glyphosat-prozess
well I never expected a round of
applause tonight chair um so um we will
we have looked previously at
Alternatives the Alternatives do not do
the job they are not good enough so uh
if we continue and do not use glyphosate
anymore the issues will be from the
residents we all know that residents
will complain more about this state Lise
we haven't got the resources to go hand
pull pull them up so um that's the
answer to questions thank you chair
thank you councilor Al so councilor WIS
you have a supplementary
question could I just clar I'm first of
all I'd like to thank thanet District
Council because I put the same question
to KCC and they don't know how many
liters they're using in thanet which is
pretty scary
uh and I find quite shocking they've
just devolved the power to the the
Spraying Company uh first of all I'd
like to ask it's a dormant season so
have we suspended glyphosate use because
it's a dormant SE SE season and if we go
back to using glyphosate please with
will this Council uh pledge to actually
informing residents where they're using
it so that if those residents decide the
research on glyphosat-prozess in the
balance but you know I can choose to go
in a room where there are smokers or not
I can't choose to not walk my dog on the
clifftop like happened on the western
undercliffe when there was glyphosate
being sprayed by TDC and I think
residents would like that choice they'd
like to know where the
glyphosat-prozess okay is that it thank
you yes I'm just making sure the Ladi is
finished yes I call upon councel alurn
to resp thank you chair um to answer
your questions councilor we um yeah is
dormant season we don't use it in the
winter it's not used um
and one of the things that we have
discussed that because obviously it was
whether we were going to continue using
it how we use it or not uh um was that
one of the things that we asked the
officers to do is to put signs up as to
where glyphosate was sprayed however
that's not an issue at the moment so um
but should we continue we will let you
know we let all members know and uh and
and signs will go up but uh I'm quite
sure I think we will try and find
Alternatives thank you very
much thank you Council
Elvin
right agenda item 7B question number two
from the member regarding judicial
review of menston airport I called upon
councelor
warro hello good evening and thank you
chair will the leader welcome the
clarity with which Mr Justice Dove
confirmed that Mr Justice Lane was
correct in determining in the high court
that Jenny dors had no arguable case for
the judicial review of the manston
airport
dco thank you councilor I call upon the
leader to
respond um I don't think Council War has
asked the question in full that he's put
on the paper I don't know if he'd like a
reply to the full question or just to
the bit that he's put thank you thank
you chairman for the opportunity to do
that and I do apologize yeah and uh and
will the chairman tell us what action
he's going to take in order to ensure
that the cargo Hub works in the
interests of thanet residents thank you
thank you would you like to respond now
leader thank you uh councilor war and
I'm sure you'd like to hear the uh the
full response that I've got for you and
not just a discussion about the legal
process um I think you've slightly
misund of the legal process if I'm
honest um it wasn't the job of Mr
Justice Dove to decide whether uh Jenny
d had an arguable case it was it was um
his job to decide the merits of the case
um that's the decision he actually
reached um as for
clarity well we've been waiting for
clarity for a very long time I don't
think we're quite there yet but um I
think the delays in the process have
been a cause of frustration um to the
council's local review process uh and a
final decision would be welcome but
there is still a further route to appeal
and until the legal processes have been
completed um there is a level of
uncertainty I'm not going to talk in
those terms I'm going to tell you what I
think
so
um once the legal processes have
concluded and if the dco stands at the
end of them the council will work with
River Ro Rivero strategic Partners to
consider all of the outstanding planning
requirements within the dco that have
been reserved for the council to
determine I just want to say that nine
years of inaction at manston have been a
lost opportunity for the whole of
thanet whichever side of the debate
you've been on because our economy needs
growth and growth could have been
delivered at manston by one solution or
the other the fact that we've had
neither has been no benefit to the
community the uncertainty has been a
light on Ramsgate because Ramsgate is
principally the area affected by the
flight path but it's north fet that
suffered most from the decision to
protect the air airport in the local
plan and in particular in July 2018 this
Council moved 25,000 homes in the local
plan from the airport largely onto
agricultural
land 1600 of those were to the rural
areas surrounding Westgate and
birchington that's in the council
minutes and anybody can see it the labor
group at the time which was very small
did not support that proposal
carbon emissions quite obviously respect
No Boundaries and they are an
issue and will continue to be what I do
want to say tonight is this
Administration will respect the outcome
of the legal
process and we will put the whole of
thanet first as we would do in every
decision that we
make after all labor councilors
represent almost every part of it now
thank
you
do you have
supplementary thank
you thank you for that councelor ett
under the leadership of Clive har and
then Irish
Johnson you and myself stood together in
support of manston
airport and in that same spirit I ask
you tonight will you once again public
declare publicly Clare your support for
manston
airport yes or no well um I have
followed your political career closely
uh councelor War um and you have of
course representing a number of
different parties over time I think
you're on the fourth one that you've
tried to stand for election for S I
don't know your own name did you get
eled about Ros that's read so probably
not but I'm proud to be a member of the
labor party so I don't and I'm
consistent about being member of the
change you couldn't get elected on your
personality don't let do
that
I I did not stand on a Manifesto um
supporting the airport in 2015 I don't
know what you were doing but I didn't um
I think that the whole issue of the
electors of thanck casting their votes
foreign against the airport has been
massively overstated by all sides let's
be clear the conservative group ran on
virtually nothing else in the local
elections and they lost they lost seats
and they lost votes but I don't think I
don't think that that was about the
airport I think that was about their
government and I don't think that
councelor Piper came seventh your former
leader in the fite independent group and
the biggest airport Advocate that there
is I don't think he came seventh because
he was campaigning for the airport I
think he came seventh cuz there were
better options on the ballot
paper what I will say to the council and
I promise the council I may have a view
on this issue and it may not be the view
of some members opposite and some
members of the public but as leader I
have a responsibility and I intend to
discharge that responsibility in a
proper
way thank you
leader
right item agenda item 7 C question
number three from a member of guarding
the reopening of Manson airport I call
upon councelor
Pew thank you chair clearly it's going
to be a long night isn't it um I don't
really want to repeat uh repeat what's
already been said but my question is
very similar to council waros um if a
little bit more clear that I've always
supported the airport um with the recent
outcome of the Manon airport judici
review announced will this
Administration finally support the
reopening of the
airport called upon the leader to
respond well I could refer councelor PE
to the answer to my previous question um
I think I'll add a little bit which is
to say that what this decision does is
establishes the principle assuming it
goes forward and I think it will um it
establishes the principle of reopening
man in the airport what it doesn't do is
prove its
viability cuz that isn't the job of the
of the Secretary of State or the
minister and it wasn't the job of the
judges and actually if you read the
reports and you read all the decisions
there's a considerable area of doubt
about its
viability some people have an almost
religious faith in everything that rivo
strategic Partners say the conservative
leaflets which I've referred to before
spoke of A500 million P investment and a
potential for 23,000 jobs which sounds
very exciting the only thing I want to
know is where these 23,000 people are
going to live cuz presumably it's going
to be in the fields of Ral F because
there isn't room for them in the
towns what we've heard from so many
people is an act of faith that River Oak
can deliver if they get the final legal
permission let's see it won't be this
Council that stops the airport being
viable but personally I remain agnostic
on
that thank you leader councilor Pew do
you have a supplementary question I do
chair um and I I thank the leader for
his response albe it wasn't the response
that I was particularly hoping for uh
but there it goes I can always live and
dream uh Council re um no but thank you
uh for your response uh my supplementary
question focuses on in particularly as
you've said about uh River Oak strategic
uh Partners um and the information that
may or may not uh be out in the public
domain um I've got a few questions uh
will the leader commit uh to in an open
and transparent way uh to have uh River
oin to present their proposals for the
airport to all counselors whether that
be at full Council or in a members
briefing um so that all members and
members of the public as well um Can
ensure that they have the facts and the
information as it is um and also will
the leader confirm uh particularly in
comments I believe he made on ITV News
or BBC Southeast one of them it
certainly wasn't GB news I know that for
a
fact will the leader confirm what he
meant uh by uh certain planning hurdles
or issues with planning that still maybe
need to be resolved in because I'd like
to to think that the leader wasn't
referring to any action by uh labor
members of the planning committee to
stop uh planning permissions being
granted for structures and buildings on
the airport site Uhl particularly as the
planning committee supposed to be
nonpolitical um okay and uh people are
supposed to make decisions thank now
thank
you hold upon the leader to
respond I don't think you were listening
carefully enough I mean I think I got
about 15 seconds on BBC Southeastern you
never know which uh which bit of the of
the comments they're actually going to
use but I certainly didn't talk about
the planning process what I said that
there are legal hurdles and there are
legal hurdles they need approval from
the civil aviation Authority and they
need lots of other Protec approvals
around the site and he knows that as
well as I do so it's a bit disingenuous
to pretend that I'm talking about the
planning process um I it's not up to me
what the planning committee do if
matters go before the planning committee
it's a matter for them and I but I'm
absolutely convinced that my colleagues
will behave with integrity and in a in
an appropriate way because that's the
way they will always behave during this
Council or they won't be in my
group can I
um I can tell I can tell councilor Pew
if he's going to listen I can tell him
that I wrote Tony freudman on September
the 29th asking him to meet senior
officers and myself so we could discuss
the way forward and how we could work
together Mr freudman has agreed to do
that and I look forward to that
conversation in the near future um I'm
very happy to say that as part of that I
will talk to Mr Freeman about him coming
and talking to members of this Council
all members of this Council so they can
ask whatever questions they
like cuz it would be ridiculous not to
do that thank you
thank you
leader agenda item 7 D question number
four from member of regarding the
restoration of Passenger services at
Manon airport I call upon councelor
Dennis point of
order John's question it's councelor
Dennis's question
chair thank you chair my question is
similar to the others will the leader
confirm his support for the airport as
they seek to restore passenger Service
as soon as possible thank
you thank you canel Denis call upon the
leader to
respond um thank you p uh councelor
Dennis isn't aware the dco application
applied for consent to primarily
establish a cargo Hub at Manon airport
with some provision for passenger
Services once the legal processes have
concluded and if the dco stands the
council will work with RSP to consider
all the outstanding planning requir M
within the dco that have been reserved
for the council to determine as for
whether there'll be passenger flights
and when they'll be I think that's
principally a matter for River Oak
strategic partners and will depend on
the market but I wouldn't hold your
breath thank
you thank you Council Dennis have you
got a
supplementry agenda item 7 a question
number five from a member regard in
Walker's construction I call upon
councelor
Banbridge thank you
chair um my questions for the leader
you'll be pleased to know it's not on
Manson
airport but it's
not very close by yeah so um Walkers
construction recently closed the
B250 at manston for several weeks during
the recent school holidays the
consequences of this were as follows the
owners of man golf club and their
children's activity center R schcool Bay
lost 60% of their expected Revenue chaos
ensued as drivers used spratling street
spratling lane and Preston Road as
uncontrolled rat runs pedestrians were
put at risk because no footpath
Arrangements were made to protect them
from the huge increase in vehicular
traffic during the road closure Stage
Coach suspended their bus service three
Monson Village leaving many people who
depend on public transport totally
isolated in view of all this can the
leader inform me of what Arrangements
have TDC made to Lobby KCC highways and
highways England to ensure that this
chaos is not allowed to happen
again thank you called upon the leader
to
respond thank you Council B um I have
every sympathy with the businesses and
residents who were affected by the
recent h Road uh Road works and although
um less of a problem to me than it was
to them um I have shared the frustration
at times U not least with the fact that
I can't turn right into Newington um and
go and visit my residents down there um
so it is a problem um Just for
information highways England was
replaced by national highways in 2021
and it manages Motorway and major
a-roads like the A2 so I don't think
lobbying them would actually achieve
anything Kent County Council um is the
highway Authority and they are
responsible for coordinating and
planning and scheduling of all work on
the publicly maintainable Highway KCC
operate a permit scheme with the
following objectives to carry out Road
Works more effectively limiting
disruption to improve the consideration
of people who live near or travel
through Road works and to promote safer
Road
works this Council receives a banc
notification of Street works and road
closures for information this ensures
the impacts on services such as
household waste collections could be
mitigated but it is notification not
consultation this Council has no Highway
um experts and has no expertise to share
on the subject I understand that the
works on the a256 h Road centered around
the Viking roundabout are an improvement
scheme undertaken in accordance with a
section 278 agreement between a
developer and the highway
Authority such works are essential for
the long-term Improvement in capacity of
our road Network the safety of temporary
traffic management is a core
consideration of the contractor and the
highway Authority when works are planned
and any concerns in this regard should
be raised directly with KCC at the time
they're observed disruption to residents
and businesses is another important
factor when planning works but where
business Representatives consider that
they've been negatively impacted by
temporary works or road closure they may
choose to raise their concerns with the
highway Authority and all the contractor
however this is not a matter for the
district
council councilor Banbridge do you have
a supplementary question um yes I do
thank you chair
um can I thank the leader for his reply
um but in doing so may I point out that
the number of housing projects currently
under construction or being planned will
inevitably require either traffic light
controls or even road closures again
stretching well into the future in view
of this can I ask the leader if he will
agree to the creation of a cross-party
working group of elected members to
Monitor and manage all future requests
from house builders to stop the FL the
slow and the flow of the road traffic
here in thanet so we have some sort of
phased response thank you thank you can
I call upon the lead respond um I'm not
sure how that would work councilor
members within our existing scheme of
governance but I'm certainly happy to
talk to officers about it um can I just
say that the County Council does have
its own councilors as you're aware and I
think that the first um Port of Call
when lobbying the County Council should
be those County counselors and it's been
pointed out to me that one of them um
councelor Shan is in the audience
tonight so I'm sure he's hearing what
you're saying and he'll take back those
messages to County Council and get you
some better action
the other thing that we can possibly do
is use the joint Transport Board um
members will know that that is not
proceeding in a very satisfactory way
and hasn't been for some time and I know
that the new chair councelor matterface
is very keen to do something about that
and make sure that it functions more
effectively so we will perhaps we can do
something through that route we will
certainly continue to Lobby KCC on that
FR thank
you thank you
leer agenda item s F question number six
from Member regarding farmland and local
plan review I called upon councelor
braywood thank you
chair the inclusion of Greenfield in the
current local plan is negatively
impacting local tenant farmers and
Farmers SL land owners alike their
livelihoods rely on being able to
continuously Farm year on year parceling
off sections for development reduces
viability of the remaining farmland
forcing them to consider other ways of
maintaining their income including
turning Farmland into solar
installations this decision is a direct
result of the local plan including land
for development on our grades 1 2 and
three agricultural land my question does
this Administration accept this and what
steps are being taken to ensure no
further Farmland is included in the
local plan review even though it may be
offered up in the latest call for sites
thank you I call upon the leader to
[Music]
respond yeah um thank you for your
question councelor briwood um as the
local planning Authority the council is
required to meet the housing needs of
the district as identif identified
through the government's housing
standard method in the 2006 local plan
the council had to meet a lower housing
Target and was able to allocate on
largely Brownfield sites in the 5 years
following the adoption of the plan over
95% of completions were on Brownfield
land
partly as a result of the successful
Brownfield first approach taken in that
plan the district does not now have a
significant stock of available
Brownfield sites other than the airport
and the 2020 plan had to accommodate a
much higher housing
requirement as part of the local plan
process the council carried out an
extensive Brownfield land search in the
absence of sufficient alternative sites
to meet the housing requirements the
council had to consider the use of
farmland the council only allocate sites
that have been submitted to it through
the call for sites process by land
owners and their land planning agents
who sometimes already have option
agreements with the developers and
development agents the scale of housing
that needs to be met and the extent to
which agricultural land can be protected
from development are largely determined
by government guidance in the National
planning policy framework and planning
practice guidance in March
2023 the Council made comments in
response to the government's
consultation on the leveling up and
regeneration Bill and proposed revisions
to the National planning policy
framework that response has been
published on the council's website and
as I've said before the labor group
through my colleague councelor White had
made its own submissions which said very
similar
things in the council's response it
argued that the current housing standard
method used by the government to
determine housing targets requires
urgent review and question the evidence
for the government's annual housing
Target the council also argued that
proper protection should be provided in
the National planning policy framework
for all best and most versatile Farmland
pointing out that in thanet grade one
agricultural land comprises some 40% of
the district's
area unfortunately both the nppf
Amendments and the review of inputs to
the housing standard method have been
delayed by the government until
2024 the extent to which local planning
authorities can protect Farmland in
future will be determined by whatever
changes the government makes to the
current
guidance and as I said earlier I have a
letter from the Department which I will
share and which will shed some light on
that thank
you thank you councilor Bray would you
have a supplementary yes chair uh thank
you councilor overit for your detailed
response um has TDC been in touch with
local farmers to ask if there are any
deric farm buildings that are no longer
used that could be renovated to provide
more housing in the district and if they
haven't could they please do
so call upon a leader to
respond um not to my knowledge but I
think it's probably unrealistic to think
that that would provide a significant
number amount of houses um it's not a
course of action that I would rule out
something we can give consideration to
thank
you agenda item 7g question number seven
from Member regarding the Edgar Road
Site being occupied by Rise I call on
Council the bay
for okay um it my question is not for
councelor is for councelor Whitehead um
as we do not currently I'm sorry it's
not word for word thank you as we do not
currently have a communal residence for
people registers as homeless I'd like to
know when the eggo Road site is like to
be ready for occupation I was thank you
thank
you thank you called upon councelor whad
to
respond thank you councelor
bayford rough sleeping and homelessness
provision is of great importance to me
principally because one of my main
reasons for first considering becoming a
counselor was my time spent volunteering
at the thanet winter shelter and my
belief that we needed to have yearround
24/7 and multi- agency
provision I've always believed that it's
our Duty as a council to provide
long-term one-site provision our first
communal residence came about the last
time I was Cabinet member for housing
during the pandemic and unfortunately
ended due to the fact that we didn't own
the building and we're only leasing it
until it was brought back into its usual
usage across this period our communal
accommodation typically hous between 20
to 25 people per night in individual
rooms with access to common areas and
multi- agency
support when this lease ended in
February 2020 3 six residents still
required support into individual
accommodation from those six four went
into temporary accommodation and two
went into rise supported
accommodation the benefits of this one
site model are clear especially for
those with complex needs through having
this communal base and Outreach we were
the first Council in Kent to
successfully offer and administer coid
vaccinations to those rough sleeping or
known to rise as well as offering
medical and dental services on site the
next step to take was to ensure that
these Services had a council-owned home
not subject to external lease or
instability of provision linked to
that these services are provided via our
rise service that provides support for
people that are at risk of rough
sleeping in the
district rough sleeping is a complex and
highly individual matter and the premise
of our rise team functions so well
precisely because it recognizes the
importance of combined Services multi
agency approaches and genuine connection
and understanding these processes are
often not shortterm and building trust
and belief in the ability of services to
help and individual's ability to empower
themselves within their own tencies is
vital this includes Outreach Services to
provide support for people sleeping
rough as well as help with finding and
managing a home and with preventing
eviction we have completed the
acquisition of a large site in Edgar
Road Margate with the long-term
intention of converting it into
self-contained homes for affordable rent
we are currently using it as our first
ever Council owned home for Rise
providing not only accommodation but
also essential on-site services and
multi-agency support for residents to
provide homes whilst building confidence
and ability to maintain long-term
individual
Tendencies this is a huge step forward
for us and an important and necessary
investment in the health and well-being
of our residents and community
it will increase the supply of available
accommodation for homeless people the Ed
road side will egg Road Site will
provide 16 units of independent
accommodation within a communal building
providing access to support as well as
more Independence and privacy than a
shelter
model we are currently completing
essential health and safety works in the
building and as soon as these are
completed the service will be able to
use the building we anticipate
residencies will begin from the 4th of
November
unfortunately as we have discussed many
times in this chamber funding
allocations are not continuous which
makes long-term rough sleeping and
homelessness planning challenging for
all
councils the Ry service currently has
Government funding through until March
2025 and will be able to use the
building in Edgar Road throughout this
period housing and homelessness is an
absolute priority for this
Administration as demonstrated by our
commitment increase our provision of
social housing and inhouse temporary
accommodation for local residents
and we will continue to bid and do our
absolute best to secure funding for
residents in need of this
service as soon as Edgar Road is
available which as stated should be by
the 4th of November we will have
sufficient accommodation to accommodate
every known rough sleeper in
Planet all those currently accepting
support from Rise will be able to access
our first ever council-owned multi-
agency rough sleeping provision which is
an exceptional achievement and I thank
rise and housing officers for all of
their work on this project
thank
you thank you Council B would you have a
suppl question yes please thank you um
thank you councelor wh I'm very pleased
to hear that uh the Ed Road site is soon
going to be available I think it's very
very important in the meanwhile and
possibly after the funding is lost it
must be difficult for the mully agency
rise staff to meet the needs of the
homeless in different locations are they
able to provide provide their full
services to as many people in need in
this way thank
you rise work in many many different
ways um so Outreach is a huge part of
what they do um
because to those who are
often unable
to either access or accept support
initially building those relationships
is very very important bringing people
to a point where they can manage
Tendencies is very important
so the communal
model as I said at the beginning of the
first question I do believe provides the
best possible outcome it allows us to
deliver all of our services in one place
and it allows us to deliver a huge
amount of support and ongoing
support that isn't to diminish at all
the Outreach support that we do both to
bring people into accommodation it being
separate and individual accommodation at
the
moment or the ongoing work that happens
after people leave the
center I
think considering the number of
discussions that we've had around this
subject I think we're both of the same
mind in terms of the importance of
communal
provision it's definitely the best way
forward and I very much look forward to
not only the facility being open but
also hopefully being able to guarantee
its future in some way from this point
forward I know that we've discussed
previously in briefings doing visits
once the health and safety checks are
completed um and would be very very
pleased for you to come um but I would
also like to offer any interested
counselors a similar opportunity to
visit visit and see what we are doing
because I think it's very important that
people are involved in all parts of
housing because this is a very complex
area and understanding how we provide
and why this support is so important is
something that's very valuable for
everyone so if there are counselors who
would be interested in looking at the
building when it is safe for us to do so
please just let me know and I'm happily
arranged for that to happen thank
you thank you councilor ahead agenda
item 7h question number eight from
Member regarding the local plan I call
upon councelor
cop thank you chair uh my question is
for the leader when the local plan which
is a legal document states that uh
developers have to supply at least 30%
affordable homes and land for schools
and doctors of surgeries how could
developers not deliver this due to it
not being
viable in the interest of local
communities and our residents how can we
allow developers to to contradict our
local plan thank you
chair thank
you I call upon the leader to
respond um well the simple answer to
that Council cup is that we don't um the
local plan States in policy sp23 that
the requirement on housing developments
of more than 10 dwellings to provide 30%
as affordable housing will only be
reduced if meeting them would demonst
make the proposed development unviable
if demonstrated and independently
verified it is not contradictory to
allow
reduction I'm sure councilor cup is
aware of a proposal at the Labour Party
Conference this week which would
strengthen the resources that Council
have to CH to support them on these
viability assessments and challenge the
developers who are quite often able to
put more resources than councils into
these
discussions of course we'll have to have
Labor government before we can Implement
that um I can tell him that there there
are no cases where land required through
planning policy for school and Doctor
surgeries has not been
provided thank you leer can I councelor
cut can I have a supplementary question
absolutely uh thank you leer for your
response that question and thank you
chair um I was also noted that uh the
labor leader Kia stama uh said in recent
radio interview that he uh was going to
ignore labor lmis and ignore labor local
counelis if they were against the local
developments but we'll we'll uh gloss
over that so let's hope we don't get a
labor government but to my question if
developers do not fulfill their promises
to deliver vital immunities for our
residents then we will see an increase
in individuals carbon Footprints due to
them traveling across the district to
Simply get a doctor's appointment so
what safeguards and conditions are you
willing to implement onto any future
planning uh application that comes
forward to ensure that developers have
to deliver for the best of thanet thank
you call upon the leader to respond yeah
councilor cup you'll be aware that one
of the challenges of the planning system
is that these developers don't actually
deliver the schools and Doctor Sur
doctor surgeries and they're not able to
they provide the land and it's actually
responsibilities of other bodies
including the Health Service G County
Council and others to provide these
facilities and that's part of the
problem so they they we can force them
to make the contributions that they're
required to make but we can't actually
deliver those services and if the
doctors AR out there because they
haven't been trained or the schools
aren't out there because there aren't
the teachers to to to run them then
there's not much we can do to the planet
to the to the developers to actually
change that situation it's a massive
problem let's let's be honest about it
and we're not going to resolve it here
this evening thank
you thank you
leader agenda item 7 I or
71 question number nine for members
regarding structural surveys of Heritage
sites I call upon councelor m
thank you chair uh I believe this
question's for councelor Orin uh keep
him busy this evening um we cannot
afford to see more of our heritage
assets allowed to fall into
disrepair and with that in mind warpole
Bay tidle
poll uh comes comes to mind uh when
please was the last structural survey
made of the chalk Reef Foundation I
believe that's called the toe uh the
actual chalk brief where the concrete
sits um and also when was the last
structural survey of the pointing of the
concrete blocks um are these
investigations part of the biannual
inspection process and if so can members
please see the most recent survey report
thank you thank you councelor MERS
called upon councelor Alber to respond
thank you chair and thank you Council of
manners uh for your question you're
quite right uh uh we can't see a lot of
our heritage allowed to fall into
disrepair uh maybe your group should
have done more when they were in power
however I'm just getting me own back I'm
just getting me own back to answer your
question to answer your question Council
MERS uh the wall Poole Bay tidal pool is
inspected twice a year by the technical
services team as part of a program of
routine Coastal
inspections the Autumn 2023 Coast
inspection is being carried out this
week and the observations from this
report can be shared for information
upon
request uh defects identified through
routine Coastal inspections are car
categorized on a priority basis for
repair most repair work is funded via a
revenue
budget however a capital Coast
protection scheme is planned in 2024 for
Walpole Bay
which will include Works to the tidal
pool the schedule of Works will include
tow protection from undermining through
erosion of the chalk wreath pointing
works and concrete repair this scheme uh
will be funded uh via a mixture of
environment agency Grant and local Levy
funding thank you chair thank
you councilor manes do you have a
supplementary question um well just on
the uh the issue with the previous
administration I find it's best to drive
a car looking out the front of the car
rather than the rearview mirror um but
uh no I mean I'm very pleased if there
is going to be a proper structural
survey I'd hope that might also include
um a look at the condition of the
concrete and the rebar within the
concrete um there are some studies out
there that suggest that concrete has a
life a useful life of 100 or so years
and the title poll is 90 years old and I
think like a lot of the people who swim
there regularly I'm very very keen uh
I'm sure everybody here is Keen to see
that asset protected as best we're able
thank
you hold upon Council alurn to respond
chair I wasn't sure if there was a
question there there or not but um yeah
I'm with you on that our
officers yeah our our officers will do a
thorough um inspection and they will
take the necessary action
thank you
chair right thank
you all right agenda item 7j question
number 10 from the member regarding the
George Osborne two child benefit cap
I've read that several times and it
puzzles me about
that I call upon councelor Austin
thank you chair no need to be puzzled I
think uh George Osborne's two child
benefit cap introduced in 2015 has been
described by a leading academic as the
worst social security policy ever far
from increasing employment it's left
families poorer with families of as many
as one in four children in our poorest
constituencies at least £3,000 worth off
what information do we have about the
impact of this cap on families in fet
what measures can we take within our own
District Council remit to reduce its
negative effects at a time when so many
families are struggling with cost of
living increases I think I've been
advised that this question should go to
the
leader well thank
you um I called upon the leader to
respond thank you chair thank you
councelor for your
question this is a long one I'm afraid
um there are a number of recent reports
from welfare agencies research and
policy units that have analyzed the two
child limit and concluded that it has
had a negative effect on families of
note is the fact that the policy has
been examined up to Supreme Court level
and found not to be in breach of the
European convention on human rights it's
important to note that even if the two
child limit were to be abolished if that
would not of itself simply hand back
lost benefit to those families caught by
it the overall National benefit cap
could come into play for some those
families if their income from all
benefits per animal to reach £
22,283 families have more than two
children what we cannot know is how many
families receive no welfare support
because of the limit I way where they
would have an entitlement to State work
or support after taking into account
their income if there was no limit on
the number of
children for housing benefit we cannot
amend the rules locally the regulations
apply nationally so the two child limit
has applied since
2017 some residents who have been in
receipt of housing benefits since before
2017 may not be impacted by the two
child limit
rule on council tax support the council
can set its own rules the scheme in
place at thanet is based on on the
traditional council tax benefit rules
which are inherently linked to housing
benefit rules as a result the local
scheme also contains a two child limit
in the majority of cases however where a
resident is in receipt of council tax
support the council could choose to
increase the generosity of the council
tax support scheme and allow payment for
more than two children but that would
come at a cost every additional pound of
council tax support is1 less council tax
collected it's not however 1 less
Council tax for this Council because it
would result in decreased revenue for
council tax perceptors such as K County
Council who as we all know get the vast
majority of the council tax
anyway any changes to the council tax
scheme would require public consultation
and a scheme can only be amended from
the 1 of April each year schemes cannot
be amended in year so thus far this
Administration has had no opportunity to
do
that fic District Council does have
funding to help local people on low
comes the household support fund is used
to assist people and for 2023 thanet
budget is 521
th000 the household support fund trans 4
is currently being allocated to agencies
across thanet to allow families who are
struggling with the cost of living to
apply for support this includes support
for household items food increased
energy costs and rent arear which is are
a result of the cost of living increases
in addition discretionary housing
payments can provide additional interim
support for housing related costs
particularly where households have
experienced an income shock the council
also provides support to its own tenants
through our dedicated Financial
well-being team this support includes
identifying financially struggling
households and there are currently 455
children living in tenants families
affected by the two child limit and 143
households affected by the benefit cap
providing benefits and money advice to
help manage finances and maximize
entitlement and making referrals
making referrals to other specialist
Support
Services finally you'll be aware that we
have committed to the delivery of at
least 400 affordable rental homes over
four years and we are delivering those
at
PACE this program will deliver a range
of size of rented homes including larger
homes for families with more than two
children thank you
[Applause]
Lether call upon Council Austin to
respond to ask the
supplementary thank you chair and thank
you leader for that very detailed
response that's much appreciated um
abolishing the two child cap is
estimated to be likely to cost 1.3
billion a year but it would lift 250,000
children out of poverty and a further
850,000 out of extreme poverty according
to NCH child poverty and other
campaigners will the leader write to the
Prime Minister and ask him to revoke the
cap and will he write to the leader of
the opposition and ask if he will
consider doing that if he should become
Prime Minister in the future thank you
thank you I call upon the leader to
respond um well I'd like to see the two
child limit uh abolished I'm not sure
that Rishi sunak is going to be hugely
influenced by um a letter that he
received from me on the subject I shall
certainly continue to Lobby my
colleagues in the labor party um and as
I said I was in Liverpool this week
doing that on very various things um I
I'd like to see some real changes in the
benefit system but what I also recognize
that this has to be done in the round
within the finances that is available in
the current situation and with an
understanding of the full context of the
impacts that could result from those
changes and I think too often we pull on
one one straw and it has an effect which
hasn't been
anticipated um so certainly I would like
to go down this route um and I think
that the path to achieving that is to
elect the labor government and um
councelor Austin you can help us doing
that by voting for Polly bingson in
vanity right thank you
leader right so so members members we
are ceasing question time anybody that's
got an outstanding question it will be
answered in writing so we're now
carrying on
to agenda item eight notice of
motion
okay one notice of motion of
receiv received in
record with Council procedure rule
three please note the time allowed for
consideration of motions shall not
exceed 30 minutes I ask members to be Su
and as possible whatever that
is right agenda item AA motion regarding
ping new planning permission from major
applications members may recall that a
motion from Council garana was received
at the last meeting of council the
motion was deferred to this meeting in
order to report detailing the financial
and legal implications of agreeing the
motion could be brought forward to
members that report is now before
members for for them to consider as
Council has already agreed to debate the
motion I will invite councilor G to
present his petition and then I will
open the item for debate at the end of
the debate I will take a vote to see if
the council adopts or rejects that
motion a call upon councelor
Garner thank you and I'll be as um
succulent as I
can this
this motion which we now have the
opportunity to debate is to pause the
granting of new plainly permissions for
builds of more than 10 dwellings so as
to allow for a review Into the impacts
the current house building program is
having across Planet I'd like to thank
officers who've worked over the last
couple of months to produce the
comprehensive report that's been
produced and to inform this debate which
I'll refer
to before I outline why I think we
should be agreeing this motion I want to
clarify a couple of things that this
motion isn't proposing firstly it isn't
proposing that all building work in
thanet should stop as much as some here
might like that to be the case as the
report helpfully points out there are
currently 748 units with planning
permission approved that developers
could be getting on with secondly it
also isn't proposing that work on
planning
applications which are yet to be decided
should be stopped
as also pointed out in the report there
are currently 26 active planning
application active major planning
applications for housing developments
some of which have been active for years
or rather than months as I've made clear
PR previously I'm proposing this motion
as a result of conversations with
residents both during the election
campaign and after about their concerns
about the impacts that the house
building program is having on our
infrastructure and I'm sure we've all
had similar
conversations we're all familiar with
the concerns about southern mors
infrastructure um so I won't go into
detail on that um we're also familiar
with other related concerns some of
which have been mentioned earlier
because they also impact our residents
both current and future res residents
that is impacts to our already
struggling GP services our Hospital our
schools and of course our roads Network
as we are reminded in the report the
provision of these Services is not our
responsibility I believe however that it
is our responsibility to call out vifly
when these Services aren't delivered and
I look forward to the data related to
the last three years being published
soon as promised in the report which
would duvail nicely into the review we
would conduct if this motion were
approved the report has made a start on
other aspects of the review too it
provides useful information on the
number of empty homes across the
district 1,1
1,551 classed as long-term empty when
you're adding the number of second homes
and the number of airbnbs the figure
approaches
5,000 it also provides useful
information about the affordable homes
which have been built in the 3 years
from 2019 to 22 is
382 which I suspect is a lot less than
30% of the total bill or major
developments during that period many of
the risks raised by officers in this
report about us during this review I'm
just finishing are predicted on this
course of action being unreasonable
behavior I do not believe it is at all
unreasonable for act on for us to act on
our residents concerns so I ask you to
support the motion and let's get on with
the review thank
you
[Applause]
right so it's me open to members debate
so if you
can it's
on just speak into the microphone just
speak into the
mic can you hear me
now bit of a malfunction somewhere
you've heard me all the way
through well thank
you right so it's open for members to
debate so ever first right so Nick will
take the names and tell me Council
Everett coun councelor Everett
um thank you chair um thank you
councelor Garner for bringing your
motion to the council um the
administration absolutely recognizes the
level of public concern about the scale
and location of plan development in
fet even though it was set out for a
full consultation process during the
adoption of the local plan going back to
2018 but we understand that people don't
pay that much attention to the detail
wake up you've got the book in front of
the
microphone apologies what I'm trying to
do is is avoid losing my voice which is
why I'm speaking slightly softly but
I'll do my best okay
list anyway what I'm saying is it's not
enough for the council to follow proper
processes it's it's important to explain
to Residents why things happen and what
the council can and cannot do at this
stage that's why we as an Administration
felt it was important to debate this
motion and to give an opportunity for
the reality to be set out by officers
not just by politicians in black and
white I want to thank the officers for
what is a comprehensive
report and I have to say that no
responsible council could pass the
motion in front of it
tonight firstly it asks for a pause in
the consideration of major
applications these applications would
simply be decided Elsewhere on the same
policy basis without local Dem ratic
input the council would face legal
costs and lose application fees which
incidently help to fund the staff who
decide all the other planning
applications none of the things
councilor Garner wants to happen during
a pause require a pause they are
subjects we deal with all the time and
they can be explored through the local
plan cabinet Advisory Group and if
necessary through overview and
scrutiny what's more at at the end of
this pause supposing it happened nothing
whatsoever would have changed because
local policy can only be amended by the
local Plan update which is a statutory
process taking
years what more apps will imperil the
affordable housing that we desperately
need in this District including the
council's own building
program the officer's report sets out
responses to the six questions posed in
the motion so I'm not going to go
through that
again but the motion produced the report
and to that extent it has served a
purpose I do feel however there's a risk
that it has misled residents about what
the council can and cannot
do voting for it tonight when in knowing
it cannot be delivered is not serious
politics it is simply performance and
our residents deserve better than
that thank you leader a call on call
upon Council
Pew thank you chair um I mean I agree
with uh the leader residents do deserve
better but unfortunately they've got a
labor Administration so that's the way
it
works well leader I'd do a lot better
than you if I was running this
Administration we leader we did a hell
of a lot uh trying to fight the housing
numbers um and former leader of this
Council wrote repeatedly to the
Secretary of State and was working very
hard uh to try and do what's best for
residents look I think we're here
tonight and this is why we're all
counselors because we're here to do
what's best for residents um it is best
for residents to I I believe and I know
that the conservative group are behind
me in supporting Council Garner's motion
it is in the best interest of residents
to support this motion to pause any new
major consents uh across the aisle um it
won't stop any who have that have
unfortunately have already been
consented from being built um but in my
mind it's concerning particularly not
just in the report but the risks that
are
associated um with supporting and
passing this motion one of them says
that the council is unable and I quote
from it planning risk the council is
unable to demonstrate a 5-year housing
Supply um and therefore we're at risk of
uh applications being successful that
are not included within or allocated
with our local plan that's been
happening for some time we've lost uh
planning appeals particularly in my old
ward in monton uh we've lost planning
pills for considerable developments
across the district um supporting this
motion won't uh make that worse it's
already happening now um so I think it's
really important uh that all members and
this shouldn't be political um that all
members support this motion um and
ensure that actually yeah we do do
what's right for residents thank
you thank
you call upon Council of
fellows thank you uh Mr chairman and
thank you to council Garner and the
greens for bringing this debate this
evening I I will support in this motion
uh a number of us have wanted a
moratorium on house building and large
planning applications for some time also
looking at ways we can call in the local
plan to have the numbers relooked at
every request has been met with a no
it's not possible so this is a chance
for us to draw breath step back and take
stock of what us as counselors and as a
council is allowing to happen here in
than our health services are maxed out
our roads are constantly clogged our
water and sewage system are in meltdown
it's clearly unsustainable position and
it's definitely unsafe no one can argue
these points the local plan is certainly
creating more issues than it solves and
that's for sure and to be clear I did
not vote for this local plan my Village
of burington is under siege from
developers with one planning application
alone and there are more it's for, 1600
houses on grade one agricultural
Farmland let's think about that number
1,600 and that won't be the end of it
and then you can clearly see the
destruction that is coming of our
Village Life forever it's absolute
Madness and it's tragic for all this
live here so if you want the best of
thanet then you will also support
Council Gardner's motion this evening
the residents of thanet are watching how
we treat this motion this evening and I
know how the residents of buron will
expect me to vote so I ask all members
here this evening will you all be doing
how you expect the residents expect you
to vote thank you Mr
chair call upon councelor
bright thank you chair and thank you
councelor Garner um I think uh and thank
you Mr Porter for your your report um
none of us want to see how's his built
on Green Field I think we all agreed on
that ideally um as has already been
discussed the Brownfield policy and the
local plan excluded the biggest
Brownfield site that we've got
unfortunately but it is what it is
well okay I'll get on with it um the
fact is what's best for um our residents
is to have safe ecologically sound homes
we need new houses there is a housing
crisis in this country that's why there
are, 1600 people in housing need in
thanet now when I bought my first home
the average house price was three times
the average salary three times that was
quite easy it was it was fine we did all
right now it's 11 times now if you think
that's a a a decent future for our
children and for our young people then
I'm going to have to disagree with you
and we talk about the risks now for me
this is about this is purely about
gesture politics there is a huge risk of
this derogation of Duty it's a statutory
duty of this Council to to uh determine
planning applications and if we don't do
it we are failing our voters and our
residents and this labor this labor
group got elected for a
reason and finally the most terrifying
thing is the pr ECT of a secretary of
state a conservative Secretary of State
the conservatives who are responsible
for those crumbling Medical Services
those crumbling school buildings and a
National Health Service on its knees and
no infrastructure around water that's
your fault it is so I don't want to hand
over any planning decisions to a
secretary we can we can laugh and joke
but there's 1600 people who are homeless
in thanet and there are no uh Medical
Services all the things you've just
pointed out the conservatives have run
this country into the ground and we will
support this uh we will reject this
motion because we need the houses and we
need a labor government and we need and
and to to hand over the uh the powers of
determination to these ecological
economical and environmental vandals
would be an absolute derogation of this
council's Duty thank
you call upon councilor
got cool okay thank you chair um okay
and thank you to uh councelor GH for
bringing forward this motion um I myself
who live in a ward which is West gon sea
is actually facing issues with over
potentially 2,000 houses being built on
Prime agricultural land um I mean we can
obviously with the point about how we do
actually need our agricultural land um
due to obviously just economic
situations you can get political about
that but I want to focus more on the
actual buildings themselves I mean
there's been a lot of posts on social
media from new residents who have
actually moved into fet and now live in
these newly large buil developments
about the problems of shi buil builds
and finishes to their homes some of the
local contractors have actually decided
not to take on any new build works
because of the problems and issues that
they've had with them and looking at the
quality of new building stock for
example we have a recent case with
sunning down Housing Development who are
currently in the process of winding up
their company leaving developments in St
Nicholas and Minster unfinished due to
building effective properties and now
will be left and in inhabitable for
loads of people I mean for me personally
I just feel that we're kind of a living
in an island that is at the moment
struggling with infrastructure um actual
movement of people for example I think
we're actually having less people having
the desire to actually move into fet so
we don't actually have the desire to
build all this housing so I do support
Mike gner with his motion that we do
need to look into this and certainly put
a pause on any new builds and definitely
these properties that are currently
popping up now that are just not
sustainable they're not affordable um
half of them don't even reach any
demographics I mean some people are
saying if you build more houses been the
housing market down it hasn't it's just
made the housing market collapse so
that's my stance in it thank
you thank you
Council councelor will
scobby thank you chair I think um I
think there needs to be some reality
added to this debate I mean there's been
a lot of um anger frustration already
coming out across people and I think
that's in some ways good in local
politics to have that passion but when
we're talking about planning and when
we're talking about strategy these
decisions were made years ago these
decisions the die has been cast on these
things and what is coming out very very
clearly in the report is that trying to
do this now is simply not possible and I
think you know representing Northwood um
a lot of this development is going to be
around Hayne and we have spent time as a
local councils trying to work out how to
engage with the community there who are
seeing their whole area change and it's
very very difficult because people want
to see action but the reality is as a
ward counselor I cannot stand there and
promise him that I can do anything about
his application because these strategic
decisions were made by Council
previously and I think the history of
thanet is one of us looking for easy
solutions so the root of the problems
we're looking at now it's not anybody's
fault necessarily in here no one person
is saying this has to happen this is
what happens when you have over a decade
of political drift and a hung Council in
thanet you have had leaders changing
corporate plan priorities changing as we
heard earlier with the questions to
cabinet members from the public and from
Members the local plan itself moving
large amounts of housing between that
lack of strategy is what we're seeing
here and you know we have to have that
reality in this debate if you want to
stop this from happening this motion is
not the way to do this you know
charitably this is people trying to do
the right thing you know uncharitably
it's as the leader said gesture politics
but this is not the way to bring about
change we have to engage in this process
of the local plan review and as
residents we will listen to you but it
has to follow the rules and there is
something that always sticks in my head
whenever we have debates like this if I
look back over the last 12
years uh when I was last on the council
over a decade ago we had the issue of
live animal exports in the port and
there was a real feeling in the council
we must do something about it we must
stop this it's awful and the council did
try and do something about it but did
something that legally it couldn't and
it ended up paying out large amounts of
money in compensation something that is
still sitting in reports recently and
impacting our reserves we cannot cannot
put future services at the council at
risk by doing things that we do not have
the power to do the report makes it yeah
no thank you very much the report makes
it very very clear this is not something
that we can do without impact it will
clearly impact our future power hours
and have budgetary impact however the
the the views that people are being put
put forward on this I do agree with but
we've got to put this through a
different process so I I will not be
supporting the motion even though I do
sympathize with residents and the
councilors that brought it forward but
the way to change this is to have
political stability and not have Motions
like this being adopted by the
council I thank you I call upon Council
Austin there will never be enough
housing it's about time you realize that
thank you
chair thank
you um thank you ex sorry a councel
Austin is trying to speak B my son has
been present at Council meetings since
he was five he's never disrupted and
he's never interrupted please extend him
the same courtesy thank you
thank you councelor Whitehead I I'm
pleased to be following on from
councilor scobby because he said he
wanted to inject an element of reality
and I think that's what we need to do
we've heard about the fire and brimstone
that's going to fall on our heads if we
take three
months to have a look at the impact of
the housing that is proposed 3 months it
that won't land in Michael Go's inbox in
3 months nobody's going to come and take
control of us in 3 months nobody is
going to have the time or the concern in
the government that as uh the leader
highlighted earlier is in a certain
degree of chaos to be interested in what
we're doing in thanet this is being
talked up as a potential disaster it's
not it's a sensible reasonable measure
for a local authority to take which is
facing being it service is being
overwhelmed that means no disrespect at
all to Bob or to his officers who've put
this information together but I do think
it's been put together on the basis of
an assumption that we're going to
somehow stop all planning and send the
planning officers home for a holiday
that's not what we're suggesting we're
suggesting a short pause a very short
pause in in considering new large
applications I noticed that there is a a
lot of emphasis in this report on loss
of democratic control and I am also
concerned about Democratic control but
it feels to me like in view of the fact
that we all know that residents are
deeply concerned about these issues that
we are taking an undemocratic st stance
if we don't actually consider taking a
short break to consider these matters in
a bit more detail thank
[Applause]
you thank you can I call on count C cup
please thank you chair um well it's been
interesting to hear what we've uh what
people have been talking about so far um
and I just want to quickly firstly say
that the only people that are making
this motion political are the labor
party because this is absolutely not
this we know what we know what are
affecting our families uh sorry our
residents considerably nonstop nonstop
and this is a time for the council to
put Party politics to one side and come
together to deliver for the residents
and listen to the
residents and I will what I will have to
say councelor Bri is you calling us
conservative what I will say is that I
am a counselor for burington before I am
a conservative member that is what I
would say to
that this is our opportunity
to actually make a change have a chance
to be a leading Co a leading Council to
say this is what we did and take a step
yes into a little bit of the unknown but
as has already been pointed out this is
a very minor delay and actually a very
minor delay could mean that it changes
the face of the potentially the local
plan and make sure that we listen to the
residents that elect us here to sit here
in this chamber I'm listening to our
residents that's what I mean I'm not
talking to you councelor Bri but thank
[Music]
you can we have a bit of debate no
calling across the chamber please thank
you chair what I would just finally like
to say um is that I will be supporting
this motion tonight uh for my residents
of burington but I am of course a
believer of making sure that we do have
housing in thanet but I think it needs
to be in the right way I did not vote
for the local plan and I think we need
to make sure that we review the local
plan in a better way and I think that
this motion allows us to do that to a
degree so thank you
chair thank you I call upon councilor
Whitehead
please oddly on one point I find myself
in agreement with councelor Cup in that
this should not be a political issue and
yet it has very very much been made one
no I'll shut
up so to go to the
report the existence of a 5-year housing
land Supply is a material consideration
in determining planning applications for
housing on sites that are not allocated
in the local plan for housing and
conversely not having a 5-year housing
land Supply makes it more difficult for
the council to resist applications for
housing on non-allocated
sites currently the council cannot
demonstrate a 5-year Supply therefore
the proposed motion would make it more
difficult for the council to resist the
development of unallocated sites as
housing applications on allocated sites
within the local plan would be delayed
or left undetermined this would give
greater weight to housing applications
on unallocated sites at appeal as the
council would not be able to demonstrate
it is attempting to provide a 5-year
Supply potentially leading to
development in undesirable areas of the
district including the green wedge and
Countryside the point is that the motion
as it stands which I would happily have
discussed at any point but did not come
to me before this
point wouldn't allow a pause we would
pause but central government wouldn't
because all those planning applications
would be referred to central government
and every developer who is already
looking at thanet as a Prime area would
watch this
meeting and then make sure that they got
applications in in order to increase
their chances of using land that we have
tried to protect this motion would not
allow a pause it's that
simple and the housing limit in relation
to developments of 10 or above we're
effectively saying we would be allowing
the expensive housing that we don't want
but we wouldn't be allowing affordable
housing which we do want because we are
can only enforce that we can only
enforce that for developments of 10 or
above so the only housing we would be
providing during this pause is housing
we don't want on sites that we don't
want so I've seen some brilliant work in
this chamber I've seen some Exemplar
cross party work and I'm thoroughly
disappointed that what's been presented
here here is being deliberately
misrepresented so it can look like
you're fighting for a pause when you
know that what will happen is central
government who have given us the rules
and regulations that are binding us and
forcing us to develop can take that
power out of our hands entirely and
force
it this motion would not give a pause it
would give more housing thank
you thank you call upon councelor
Davis thank you chair at least I'll get
to speak on this item because I'd like
there's been a lot of comments however
we are first and foremost elected by the
electorate and we are here to represent
you as councelor cup said before our
party affiliations and let me assure you
that every single colleague of mine on
this side of the chamber has your
interests at at heart we are we are
traumatized by what is going on and
why if I can actually be heard what has
caused this let's get context on this
the local plan is a subject of great
discussion here however if we go back to
pre25 to a labor Le Administration the
local plan was ignored by successive
labor leaders and administrations it was
then ignored and not delivered by the
failed ukip Administration the
conservative Administration came in and
put the local plan into place with due
haste which is a matter of record it was
then because of the delays and the lack
of protection for all of us caused by
administrations on the other side of the
chamber we are vulnerable there's a lot
of waffle about manston and Brownfield
sites the local plan and neighborhood
plans which Ramsgate in particular has
been failed by an individual for the
last 10 years support this Council
support a break we need a fire break we
need to send a robust message to Across
the chamber and to Parliament that this
community has had enough we're sick and
tired of being sick and tired and I for
one will be supporting this
motion thank
you Council
El yeah thank you thank you chair I'm
sorry people are getting n i rate uh
it's not a right thing to do on a debate
like just passionate um yeah yeah I
quite enjoyed it councilor Davis you
know it's fun
um I think the basis of the basis of
this is as is as has been said already
we're all
agreed no one wants our grade one grade
two grade three agricultural land to be
built on that's everybody in this room I
guess right okay who sold the
land who wants the land to be built on
the farmers don't know you shouting at
the farmers the farmers put the land up
the farmers put the land
up yeah well that's what I'm saying why
aren't they shouting at them
now the facts the facts of the
matter the land
pardon yeah we're nationalize it yeah um
the facts of the matter are
that has been said in relation to
planning applications if you get a
planning application for 11 houses that
can be done that this is under your
motion that that can be that can't be
done sorry that can't be done why you're
not stated an amount of houses we're all
moving about 1,600 houses but you got
someone who could come in with a plane
application for for 11 hours and you're
saying they can't put that in
that that is what you're
after the end of the day this
Council has to carry out a statutary
duty means it has to to determine
planning applications once they're
submitted if it doesn't do that within
an 8we period the developer the
householder whoever it is who's made the
application goes to government for n
determination we've seen what's happened
with non
determinations we've all F we've all
fought on the planning committee against
major
developments where we've said no to
Major developments councilor Garner
councel Austin me councelor bayford and
others last year we fought those because
they wouldn't put 30% affordable
housing they wouldn't build it they they
came back we say we want 10% we want 50
we we can't afford it what happened to
that it went to appeal and they won the
appeal we lost the appeal and we got we
didn't actually get charges against the
council because it it was a fair way
that that we actually did it but if this
happens if this pause happens and what's
going to happen in three months what you
what do you expect to achieve in 3
months you won't achieve anything in
three months we make a change it it
won't no it won't make any changes at
all there'll be no changes in 3 months
we've got to do is we have a statutary
duty as a council to carry out the the
planning applications and to determine
them otherwise it the government it'll
all go to government and we'll end up
having cost against us for
non-determination
right we've gone past the time limit now
so that the no more debate in it no
that's not fair it may not be fair but
that's what it's going to be this is an
important
issue had 30 minutes that's it minutes
30 minutes that's
it can I repeat it again youve run out
of
time no they don't know
me it's within your this is not fair
right councelor GH will you sum up
please sorry if you are a minority party
we sit here and we listen to these two
groups of people having a
Barney commense de
so come on now we've got a lot to get
through tonight there's been a good
debate on it on both sides and we're
going to move on councilor Garner will
you please sum
up
Financial
risks Council gner will you sum up
please the debate is
over please and because we're humans
you're going to
see
it it looks like we go here all night
then I'm waiting for Council of Ghana to
sum up and that's we're not moving on
until it
happens to autocracy j i you know I
actually want to bring some calmness to
the
situation because no you're not allowing
me to speak so far we just
listen
can I can I make a can I make a
suggestion please is
a you can sum up please when we started
this debate you had 30 minutes I read it
out that applies to all of
you
I um can I can I make a suggestion
please as uh
if if I'm right I mean I was some of the
things I was going to say was about um
gesture politics and taking the Ang go
out of stuff and and I believe I do have
five minutes um so there is five minutes
left for for for this debate to go on so
I'm I'm quite happy to allow um
councelor Wing to make her Point she
had so she's not even
next wasting time you've had 30
minutes be here all night
so on
so I know one or there are one or two
people I think who did have their hand
up quite early on that were that haven't
been seen and I'm not I don't that's
anybody what we're going to do now is
move to the votes right so if you don't
sum up you'd lose that
right my my my summing up which I would
have which I would have been happy to
allow Council Wing to do for me but and
any else who wasn't able to to speak is
that um it's a shame that all those who
who want to speak aren't able to speak I
was going to I mean I've lost my truck
now a little bit from what I was going
to say I have heard as councilor Wing is
said we've heard quite a lot of B well
I'll call it banter a bit of gesture in
politics from one side to the other it
has got a bit angry I didn't want to be
angry I haven't raised this I haven't
raised this motion because of of gesture
politics at all I'm quite openly saying
I'm raised this motion cuz we all heard
from our residents we've all heard not
just the people here but the people who
we've spoken to during the election
campaign the people who we speak to
since the election campaign they've all
asked us to do this I was going to say
that yes we've heard about the the risks
that have been outlined in the report
they are risks they aren't what's going
to happen happen and I believe that the
report does overplay some of the risks I
don't believe the secretary of state is
sitting there waiting to intervene in
thanet um because we decide to pause not
to pause approval of any planning
applications uh we not to propose work
to pause work on any plan applications
just to pause approval on these major
ones while we have the have this review
even if there's been questions about
well what what is the point what what is
the point of of doing this review well
even if it is to show that we have
listened to our residents we have done a
review we've outlined what the problems
are and there are issues there are major
impacts that aren't outlined in the
local plan that have happened that we do
need to we do need to um outline them
document and we might during that review
c um decide well look these these are
the major detrimental impacts and we do
need to start um lobbying further for
changes to be made um but I'm going to
leave leave it there we've heard from
one side we've heard to the other I'm
not this isn't a whatever you think this
isn't a political thing this is because
we've heard what people have had to say
and we're acting on it so we'll go and
vote thank you councilor G
and we now move to the vote ch
ch record your vote no hang on so over
50% of the people in the in the council
have to vote I'm just taking instruction
so if over half the number of councilors
here vote for a recorded vote we will
have a recorded vote so can we have a
show of hands on a recorded vote
please
say it
again yeah we have we need
40% 50 50% of councilors agree on a
recorded vote so do you agree on a
recorded
vote raise your hand ra yes raise your
hand
[Music]
and now against the recorded
vote
lost we are not going to have a recorded
vote thank
you so all those in favor of the motion
please raise your
hand repeat
it all those in favor of the motion
please raise your hand
J
who against all those against the
motion
28 that is so the motion is
lost right you can put your hands down
any Obion any Obion any abstentions
please
right the motion is
lost thank
you item agenda item nine leaders report
are called upon the
[Music]
leader thank you chair
um
happy to give my report if members are
ready to listen to it even as the polls
closed in May this Council was faced
with news that the GMB has successfully
baled our waste collection staff to
agree to take industrial action in
pursuit of their 2023 24 pay claim as
we've SE seen elsewhere bin strikes not
only disrupt the service for residents
they damage public confidence in the
council thanet is unique in East Kent in
providing its service inhouse which
means that staff benefit from local
government terms and conditions and also
that what we pay them impacts across the
council I'm delighted therefore that
last month we were able to reach an
agreement that not only resolved the
dispute with the gmbb but also enabled
us to settle unison's
20242 pay claim at an affordable level
giving us certainty for the budget
process ahead this was only achieved
through the hard work of senior officers
and I'd like to thank everyone involved
for enabling us to reach a solution
without a single day of disruption for
our residents
we have been working over the summer
months to address a number of other
Legacy issues Ramsgate has been without
its weekly Market since coid and
promises that it would resume when
unfulfilled this is something we took a
decision to act on in our first cabinet
meeting in June the market went out to
Tender in August and I'm delighted to
confirm that we have now appointed an
experienced operator to deliver it from
April next
year it's a similar situation with the
lifts in Ramsgate world Harbor car park
funding for which was already in the
budget when the last Labor
Administration left office in June
2021 these have been out of action since
coid members from the last Council will
know that I raised this repeatedly with
the previous cabinet nothing happened a
tender for those Works has now been
issued and I'm confident that we will
soon have working lifts at Leopold
Street
again in January 20122 councelor critton
brought a motion to this Council calling
for a districtwide parking review
cabinet agreed in April 2022 to carry it
out guess what happened next it was left
to this Administration to carry out the
review some 18 months
later now those of us who've been
involved in local government for a while
know that there are always practical
reasons for delay it takes political
will to get things done but we cannot
expect residents to have confidence in
the council's intentions for the future
such as cabinet will set out in the
draft corporate plan next week if it
hasn't delivered what it's promised in
the past and on the subject of promises
here's a key difference between the
political parties going into May's
election labor brought a modest proposal
for additional street cleaning resources
to the budget meeting in February the
conservatives said there was no money
for it and voted it down we told voters
in the election that we would introduce
extra sleep cleaning in residential
areas if elected and we did and within
the adopted budget in Late July the
staff that we deployed had collected 839
bags of litter and 1,200 131 bags of
leaves at the last
count members will be aware that we are
now proposing to increase the street
cleansing resource on a permanent basis
in next year's budget which will be a
26% uplifting staff and this will make a
difference but we need to do more more
to improve our open spaces and more to
tackle graffiti and fly
tipping all the parties that have read
this Council over the last 13 years have
had to deal with shrinking resources but
things have gone too far I think we have
to be honest and say that the number of
Staff in these areas is a critical
factor in what we can deliver we've not
been able to reach the standards our
residents expect for some time and we
don't currently have enough money to put
everything right but our promise now is
that we will make things better and that
includes working with the new
broadstairs and S Peters Town Council on
bringing Victoria Gardens back up to
standard because I know that's upset
residents this
year we must also not lose sight of the
hard work that does continue this summer
the council installed 80 additional
purple wheelie bins 75 large waste bins
and 30 mixed recycling bins in locations
around the coast this led to over 2,000
tons of waste and just over 30 tons of
recycling being collected from Coastal
bins across the summer season Bay
inspectors handed out litter sacks to
encourage Beach users to manage their
waste and our dedicated Beach Crews were
were on duty every day from 6:00 a.m. to
8:00 p.m. picking up litter and emptying
bins beach toy collection points were a
big success allowing Beach users to
leave unwanted toys for others to enjoy
Coastal Enforcement Officers patrolled
the coast seven days a week they took
part in a successful multi- agency
operation in August to combat the
irresponsible use of jet skis which was
threatening Wildlife around pegwell
Bay as everyone knows we had major
challenges with the volume of seaweed
which saw us remove over 1,000 tons and
that did cash us out I know that
businesses at Viking Bay in particular
were frustrated by the effects of
pollution forecast from the environment
agency which affected their trade the
state of our public toilets across the
aisle is an ongoing concern and another
promise at the start of this year which
went unfulfilled that work will be done
to improve the external appearance of
those at BR
Harbor this situation cannot continue
and it won't cabinet has asked officers
for a of Works to be prepared and as
soon as possible I think in December at
the cabinet meeting we will put that
into the public domain because they have
visitors and our residents deserve
better in the months ahead we will
continue to tackle long-standing issues
we will finally repair the access road
to hars down Leisure Center and a TDC
own section of Monte Fury Avenue that LE
leads to King George I 6 Park and we
will work with Ramsgate Town Council to
resolve the issues with the East Cliff
lift
I am both excited by the proposals for
additional Council homes that councelor
Whitehead and the housing team are
bringing forward with another TR on the
agenda tonight and troubled by the
continuing both pressures on temporary
accommodation I know that housing is
working flat out to deliver for the
people affected but for those without a
long-term solution that will be little
consolation this Administration will
expand and accelerate the provision of
our awardwinning in-house temporary
accommodation and end the need for out
of area placements saving every Council
taxpayer money but it cannot be done
immediately and in the meantime I want
to acknowledge the hard and often
stressful work being done by our
officers as well as the frustration of
those placed out of area I also want to
congratulate our private sector housing
team on winning the Kent housing group
award their work is vital and it's great
to see it being
recognized last week I attended the
engagement session at the wole Bay hotel
which show focused the Margate Town deal
plans for wole Bay and sort public
feedback I'm really looking forward to
seeing how that element of the scheme
progresses and I know there was a good
turnout of residents and this follows
the successful engagement session in
Ramsgate in the summer it's inevitable
that as we work through the detail of
these schemes we have to make
adjustments and alterations not least
because of inflation the government has
recognized this by including F in a
Pathfinder project which will simplify
reporting structures and enable more
agile local decision- making
I wrote to the Secretary of State at the
department of leveling up housing
communities at the end of August
outlining the particular challenge of
inflation and for once we got a quick
and succinct response in under three
weeks from the new leveling up Minister
Jacob Young and the government isn't
going to help despite that I am
confident that we will deliver the vast
majority of projects that have been
funded and we're shortly be going out to
Tender on the port operator for
Ramsgate I also want to mention the
successful disposal of the Westbrook
lodia to Tracy Em which is a really good
solution for that building and I know a
popular one
locally at the end of September I
attended the violence against women and
girls conference organized by the fic
Community safety partnership in
broadstairs this was a really impressive
event and I was pleased to learn about
the ways we're engaging with Cutting
Edge technology including Ai and virtual
reality to find Innovative approaches to
tackling this problem this is a serious
problem for our community like others
and as the father of daughter I do have
a personal perspective but it affects us
all we should be proud of the work that
is going on here Kemp police were able
to highlight a declining trend of
offenses as a result and I hope the
community safety team will share details
of their good practice with members our
briefing before too long finally we have
begun the process of contributing to The
District boundary review which will come
to full council with a proposal for a
future number of councilors in December
following completion of this process
some Parish boundaries may need to be
redrawn through a community governance
review to reflect the new Wards I want
to commit tonight to this Council
carrying out a community governance
review for
Margate we have pledged recently to
strengthen our relationship with town
and Paris councils across thanet
Ramsgate broadstairs and Margate sorry
Ramsgate broadstairs and Westgate
already benefit from active and I may
say well-led town councils and I respect
the contribution of the parish councils
too A Town Council for marget is long
overdue and I know that the current
Charter trustees agree this
Administration will enable that to
happen in 2027 in line with the next set
of Parish and District
elections thank you
leader I called upon C councilor Pew to
comment on or ask questions in
relationship to the leader
report thank you chair and um and thank
you councelor ever uh for your report um
I'd like to thank you for advanced site
of the report for today as well um don't
worry I understand that the low party
conference is quite exciting I'm glad to
hear that you had a good time um I won't
be throwing any glitter on you at any
point but I do have a a yes to manston
badge if you'd like it um you're more
than welcome to have it I note the
leader's remarks on the resolution of
the pay dispute with our waste
collection staff I'm delighted that this
dispute has now been resolved not least
because I know that inflation is high
and all of our staff deserve to be paid
fairly however I think it is telling
that we will later tonight have a
proposal brought before us to raise our
members allowances by over 10% at a time
when our staff will be seeing nowhere
near the same increase it is a rash
decision and I think it speaks volumes
that this is a clear priority for this
labor
Administration the leader has spoken at
Great length about his administration
getting things done and I'll be honest
I'm somewhat relieved isn't it great to
look and uh look at what we can all
achieve when we have a brilliant team of
senior officers who can work in a
positive open and transparent
environment I find it astonishing that
the leader has focused uh on recent
events whilst neglecting to mention the
20 or so months of inaction under his
previous administration during that time
the previous labor Administration sat on
its hands whilst a toxic culture
persisted at this Council the leader has
assigned blame to the previous
conservative Administration for in
action when it was the conservatives who
worked incredibly hard to resolve the
complex issues uh that this Council face
at a time when no one else would labor
can now reap the benefits our hard work
and I urge the leader to now focus on
the bigger
picture and so I ask particularly with
all of these new services and and uh
particularly uh new services that are
being provided um how will these new
Services be funded at a time when this
Council uh when we left this council
with a sound budget it appears that
labor are up to their old tricks again
spending money that they don't have and
leaving the conservatives to pick up the
pieces it's interesting to hear the
leader reference the considerable amount
of seaweed that was cleared from our
beaches this summer particularly when
the labor group Oppo uh proposed in the
previous budget before the last local
elections to remove around about £45,000
from this specific budget again the
previous conservative Administration put
a stop to that um so I'm delighted to
see the leader reference a good position
of conservative policy that is actually
working whilst the leaders report was
extensive I think it's important to know
what is missing any reference of the
biggest opportunity for economic growth
and employment opportunities that thanet
has seen for decades manston airport and
I think that speaks volumes clearly this
Administration is a long way to go uh
but it's not just about getting
headlines chair it's about doing the
hard work to deliver uh for thanet
residents thank you I call upon the
leader to
respond um yes uh thank you councilor
Pew for your
response um allowances we're going to
talk about them later I think we should
just be clear that what you're talking
about in terms of the GMB in unison is
an annual pay increase what we're
talking about in terms of members is the
first increase for 10 years in fact 11
years I don't think the two things can
be accurately compared I absolutely um
agree with what you say about our senior
officers I think we've got a great team
of senior officers and a growing team of
senior officers and you know I'm happy
to acknowledge the part of the prev
conservative Administration um played in
for example the appointment of the chief
executive I think it's been a great
success I'm delighted to work with him
and I think we're doing good things
together um if you want to talk about
the previous labor Administration you
know although you choose to overlook the
fact that it took place almost entirely
during coid lockdowns um it was very
difficult for the council to do things
outside the council during that period
we did actually deliver for our
residents a huge number of services and
officers worked really hard so there was
a great deal of work during coid and I
think that was recognized externally as
well as internally which is one of the
reasons the government wouldn't
intervene in this Council despite our
senior management issues and of course I
did initiate all the processes that led
to the changes in the senior management
team the formal processes which were
necessary before the council could make
the decisions but I've never denigrated
councelor Ashby's role in that she
played her part she knows that I think
that and she knows what I did too um
it's not necessary to divide on
political terms on that I think actually
the conservative group increased the
budget by 19.6% last year
um so I'm not quite sure what they're
accusing us of um the budget is going to
be up for examination over the coming
months we can talk about those figures
then um yeah I certainly agree that uh
we didn't have enough resource to remove
seawe but the main problem was we didn't
have anywhere that we could take it and
we didn't have an environment agency
license to remove anymore don't think
that environment a agency license was
set under this Administration but I
could be wrong it was an exceptional
year um and we need to do better man a
report isn't in the
report thank you leader I call I call
upon councelor gar to comment or ask
questions in relationship to the
leader's
report thank you
chair I'll start by thanking the leader
for early sight of his report and join
him in thanking officers for the hard
work they put in to reach a paining and
conditions agreement with the gmbb and
Unison he's mentioned several issues in
this report which need to be urgently
addressed and our hard work in waste
collection staff will be key to solving
many of them so it's right and proper
that their claim was settled promptly
and
fairly but you are committing to the
rate Market returning next April is
excellent news for residents and
businesses in the town who benefit from
The increased footfall can you confirm
that the market will be held in the Town
Center we welcome your confidence that
the lifts at the Leopold Street Car Park
will soon be work working again will you
be aiming for them to be open in time
for people to use when they visit the
market when it opens next
April we also welcome the proposals for
more Council homes which we'll hear more
of later and congratulate the private
sector housing team on winning their
reward we hope we'll be able to use our
purchasing power with developers to
ensure that the housing we're
considering buying is properly insulated
and incorporate sustainability features
to help keep residents bills down and to
help save the plantet
that the long overdue parking review is
finally going to happen is also good
news although we would have liked to
have seen more member involvement in
setting the parameters of the tender
while this is an issue that affects the
whole of planet we know there are
hotpots especially in coastal areas like
Kingsgate during the summer and we look
forward to being involved in both
responding ourselves and promoting the
consultation sessions to Residents and
businesses in our
Wards there are a couple of areas you
mention in your your report which I'd
like to focus on littering in our parks
and on our streets and the atrocious
state of our public
toilets there aren't easy fixes for
these problems and they can't be solved
by DD TDC alone but the changes
Administration plans to implement need
to be done in an open and transparent
way so that residents lots of whom
already helped through Community groups
and one or two who are here this evening
can get involved and know about changes
before before they happen this is
currently isn't always the case as an
example the Vincent close Park in some
Peters which is very popular with dog
walkers from both Ramsgate and
broadstairs has over the last few years
seen several residents from both towns
get involved in litter piics and has
become a popular community meeting point
so they were disappointed a few weeks
ago when the dog poo bins along the
treelined walkway were removed without
any Replacements leaving only one bin in
the Park right next to the entrance to
the playground for dog walkers to
deposit their waste as I said earlier
littering isn't an easy problem to fix
but a reduction in the number of litter
bins and a reduction in the number of
times they're empted sure surely can't
be part of the solution I use the above
as an example as I have firsthand
experience of the issues it's caused but
it's occurred in other parts of the town
and across a district which I'm sure a
number of us here could recount
doing something about the atrocious
state of public toilets will certainly
not be easy but we agree that it is
something that must be tackled urgently
and we're pleased to hear your
commitment to do so while public toilets
need to be a facility open to everyone
all options need to be considered
including local business sponsorships
and potentially charging to use them in
some places we've seen what can happen
when public toilets are closed at busy
time
and it's our residents who bear the
brunt having to clean up mess that no
one should have to find in their front
Gardens or indeed their neighborhood we
look forward to seeing the
administration presenting a plan to
ensure that our residents don't have to
face these issues again next
year and finally you've recognized the
work done by broadstairs and Peters Town
Council throughout your report which is
good to hear since the election all of
us on the Town Council from across the
political parties have shown how it is
actually possible to work hard together
to put together a strategy to make the
town a cleaner safer and Kinder place to
live and to visit and we are looking
forward to implementing that plan with
taking over the upkeep of the flower
beds in Victoria Gardens from TDC near
the top of that list the more help you
can give to get them licensed to the
Town Council as soon as possible the
better it will be for everyone so as we
can get on with doing it thank you very
much thank
you from the
leader um thank you councelor Garner um
yes I'm delighted to say that Ramsgate
Market will be where Ramsgate Market
always was why we ever had to have a
discussion about putting it somewhere
else I have no idea um I'd be very
disappointed if the lifts aren't in
action by the time Ramsgate market
returns um these procurement procedes
are un predictable but I am pretty
confident we're going to deliver that
um yeah location uh and and of bins and
disappearing bins certainly is an issue
I think um we've got a new head of
service in that area I'm sure he's going
to get on top of that problem very soon
um and we'll have better news in respect
of it and the public toilets we've
covered off we will be dealing with
um there will be plenty of opportunity
for involvement in the parking review I
don't think the parking review will be
successful if we don't get in engagement
from counselors and residents that's
what it's always been about and in
respect of uh Broad Town Council um yes
I know that you and others have been
working closely with councelor bright
and others on boair Town Council and
that there seems to be a real vibe there
I was really pleased to go along to a
meeting there um in the summer to hear
from all the community groups about what
they wanted from broadstairs um there
was a real sense of purpose and optimism
and I hope we can carry that forward and
that TDC can contribute to that
thanks thank you leader I call upon
councilor warro please for comment on or
ask questions on the leader's
report thank you chair I wish to thank
the leader for acting on my court at the
last council meeting when I called for
Street
cleanness it's actually quite flattering
to see the leader putting one of thanet
Independence Manifesto pledges into
action and with the good news about
manston airport we can now look forward
to seeing yet another one of thanet
Independence Manifesto pledges put into
practice I would also like to
congratulate the leader for not
mentioning in in some in his reports
some of the most important things that
matter to the people of
thanet the leader told us about his
visit to the wole Bay Hotel in
cliftonville but he very conveniently
forgot to mention the oval Bandstand
project just down the road which is
Administration withdrew £500,000 from
oh and I must congratulate the leader on
not mentioning wait for it the thanet
parkway station or as Ramsgate KCC
counselor Karen conine calls it a
monstrous dangerous white
elephant it speaks volumes when the
labor Deputy leader at KCC doesn't even
support cancer overit position on such a
major
project this Administration is still
very Ramsgate
Centric but I am however pleased to hear
the leader talk about the good news that
Tracy Emon has bought Westbrook
logia or as it's known to locals
Westbrook
calf I'm sure Tracy won't mind me saying
this but I hope she cooks a better
breakfast than she makes a
bed no but on a more serious point on a
more serious point I think it's great
for our area and I wish show the the
best of luck we we need people like
that okay we're running out of time so
I'm going to hand back to the chair now
for the leader reply thank you thank you
councelor lot of questions there thank
you call upon the
leader um thank you chair thank you
Council War for your your comments I've
got to be honest I wouldn't know what
was in the plan Independence Manifesto
or even that they had one um CU I didn't
notice
them noticing this now though
um certainly the residents of Northwood
didn't think much of the independence
Manifesto when they voted councelor
Piper into Seventh Place um in terms of
the overal Band Stand I'm very
disappointed that that project has
fallen by the wayside and I would pay
tribute to the officers who worked
extremely hard to try and reach a
solution whereby um the people
delivering it from grass would sign the
grant agreement but it's quite clear
that we can't proceed
um without um somebody can't have
£500,000 of public money if they're not
prepared to sign a grant agreement um
and that decision in the end was taken
by the1 Officer he's the appropriate
person to take it and I'm sure if You'
got any queries about why that happened
he'd be happy to tell you why that
wasn't the right thing to do um this man
about us being Ramsgate Centric well
we've got four mgate Charter trustees
out of six cabinet members um councelor
Alin is the only member of Ramsgate Town
Council on the cabinet um I must have
extraordinary dis proportionate
influence on behalf of my residence in
Newington where that the case I wouldn't
apologize for it but I intend to deliver
for all areas of
pic thank you
[Applause]
leader agenda item
10 report of the chairman of the
overview and scrutiny panel I call upon
Council fellows to present the
report uh thank you Mr chairman I'll
keep it brief as time is getting on uh
it's been a busy time for scrutiny panel
recently as we look to scrutinize all
key decisions made by this Council uh we
currently have an ongoing scrutin review
underway LED excellently by councilor
briter looking at the negative impacts
of Tourism within thanet and we look to
forward to that report in the new year
uh my full report is in this evening's
agenda pack circulated to members and
I'm happy to take any questions and
comments thank
you thank you do members have any
comments no
no thank
you agenda item 11 adoption of the
Westgate onc neighborhood plan a call
upon upon the
leader I'll keep this one
short I move that the council make the
Westgate onse neighborhood
plan I'll second that right
seconded thank you
right agenda agenda item 12 annual
treasury management review 20122 stroke
23 thank you chair um this report
summarizes a backward look on our
treasury management activity for 2022 23
the figures remain provisional because
of our 2122 and 22 23 accounts have not
yet been audited uh and therefore
subject to change until the audit is
completed
firstly I am pleased to report that all
our activities operated by officers were
were within the limits agreed by members
although there was a Minor error by one
of our financial providers this was
picked up very quickly and reported in
our midyear report to council the other
key messages that have summarized um
from the report are the council's gross
debt also called the borrowing position
at 31st March 2023 was 19.9 Million the
council's underlying need to borrow to
finance its capital expenditure also
called the capital financing requirement
uh was 52 Mill million 52.2 million at
31st of March 23 uh therefore it can be
report that the council has complied
with its requirement to hold less gross
debt than its CFR um which is the
capital financing requirement um the
maximum debt hel held by the council
during 2022 23 was 20.2 Million which
was well within the statutary authorized
limit of 96 million at 31st of March 23
the council's investment balance was
60.6 Million
um a marked reduction in general fund
Capital receipts over the last few years
which has implications for funding the
future Capital program um I move the
recommendations as contained within the
report can I have a
second coun duckor
counc councelor Duckworth right we got
councelor
Duckworth do me do members agree agree
thank you agenda item 13 budget
monitoring 2023 stroke
24 will members please refer to the
supplementary I call upon councilor
Yates thank you chair the council
Constitution requires that supplementary
budgets must be approved by Council in
other words only Council can agree to
the overall size of the budget for the
year to be increased the qu to1 budget
monitoring report was received by
cabinet on 21st of September 23 with
within which cabinet agreed for a number
of additions to the budgets to be
recommended for Council today for
approval the link to this budget
monitoring report is included for
reference under an under the annex to
this report I move the recommendations
contained within the report as set out
and these are that the council approves
the supplementary budgets for the 10K
requirement for the legal system upgrade
to be funded from reserves are set out
in section 2.1 the £54,000 identified in
section 2.2 from the business rates
growth Reserve to fund the legal and
procurement fees associated with Port
projects and that the council approves
the supplementary Capital budgets
numbers 1 to 7 inclusive as set out in
section three to this report thank you
thank you can I have a
second second
up
who youve got one
right
[Applause]
do we
agree do members agree all right do
members agree AG thank
you agenda item 14 Amendment amending
the members allowance schem 2023 stroke
24 I call upon the
[Music]
leader uh thank you chair um
there is no good time to increase member
allowances but there's also a point
where it ceases to be sensible to avoid
doing so the level of inflation over the
last 18 month months has been the
highest in many years fic's basic
allowance of
4570 a year is 25% lower than it would
have been had inflation been applied
since 2012 13 but over that period no no
increases have been applied at
all in consequence thanet now has the
lowest allowance of any kind
Authority none of us is here for the
money whether that's the basic allowance
or the special responsibility allowances
but it's unreasonable to expect people
to give up so much of their time for an
Ever decreasing rate of
compensation particularly because we're
all committed to our residents we all
want to work hard on our Wards and we
need the time to be able to do that I
appreciate that some counselors don't
need any allowance but if we are to
reflect our community properly we must
recognize that some do
these proposals are for a 10%
increase not a 10% annual increase but a
10% increase since 2012 after 11 years
they will not bring the allowance back
to their level of 10 or 20 years ago we
will still have the second lowest
allowances in Kent but this is a
proportionate and reasonable step to
addressing the
problem The Proposal is to link the
allowances in increases in future to
staff pay which which means that we will
not have to have a similar discussion in
my opinion and I hope for the rest of
this
Council I'm moving um option A which is
at 5.1 in the
report um to adopt the proposed amended
2023 for 24 members allowances scheme
has set out in Annex one to the report
inclusive of a 10% increase to basic and
special responsibility allowances and to
index link a yearly increase in
allowances to the cost of living
increase and for that proposal to go
before the East Kent joint independent
remuneration panel Fally known as
ejer the remuneration panel can then
make recommendations back to the council
any recommendations can be considered by
council at a future meeting and if no
recommendations are received from ejer
the council is asked to delegate the
authority to approve the final scheme to
the section 151 officer thank you can I
have a second
Council Council of whad
the item can be C
wi people want to debate so lots of
people want to do
it Wing thank you my hand was up first I
need some clarity because I actually
have a paid parking Bay on Harbor Towers
and had to exclude myself from the fee
and charges increase if we link any
subsequent counsel increase in allowance
es to officer pay Rises then surely we
would all have to declare an interest
and actually remove ourselves from a
vote because technically we'd be voting
to give ourselves an
increase thank
you Sam Samir can advise on that hello
Samir can advise on that if you go to
Samir what not now yeah now yeah so so
the legal Beaver wants to advise you on
something so thank you
thank you chair there is a blanket
exemption in relation to fees and
charges that you're referring to so we
don't wouldn't be needed to decare any
interest when it comes to that
particular
item if we're linking a vote that we
would take if we're linking a vote
allowances to staff I think that's what
you said councilor Everett uh then
surely we'd have to declare an
interest can I make a point of
clarification chair please I Council
over it I I I think the I understand
what you're saying Council Wing but I
think the issue is Council does not make
a decision about pay rates for staff
that's made by officers out of the
budget so um they're not it's not a
decision that councilors
make we put the money into the budget
but we don't decide as counselors what
the pay rights are that's for the head
of service to make that decision and
that's why there wouldn't be the
conflict of interest part anything
else right councelor Davis you put your
hand
up uh thank you chair uh just for the
record I'd like to uh remind
our so sorry sorry forgot myself for a
moment uh I would like to remind our
colleagues on the other side of the
Chamber of their uh alleged socialist uh
uh
credentials uh I know champagne has gone
up quite quite a lot in the last couple
of years um I think it's extremely
churlish that when we've just awarded
5.7% to the dustman who work very hard
in adverse uh conditions that they would
want to award themselves a 10% increase
but then I guess the labor party's got
to get its income from somewhere I will
not be agreeing to this because we serve
the public we're here to do a job and
this is a this is an allowance to help
us do that it is not
a salary or an income and I therefore
will not be supporting this
motion right Council
whad thank you very much
chair it's interesting to come after
that statement
because I joined this Council five years
ago as a disabled single mother with not
much chance of champagne to be honest
and I think trying to turn this into
something related to
wealth is somewhat extraordinary
considering that we have the lowest
rates of counselor allowances in Kent
and again trying to equate that with
recent pay Rises for
employees makes no sense in the context
of there being a decade without increase
for
counselors I will open
admit that my opinion has changed on
this so when I first
joined like most counselors I think and
hope my main
focus yeah I'm sorry I do tend to have a
delay because I'm autistic so it does
take me a while to get words
out so when I first joined I did have a
different opinion in that I think most
of us join because we want to serve the
public we don't join because we look at
the allowance and think wow that's a
huge amount and I'm definitely going to
go for that we join because we want to
make a difference in some way and so to
me at that point it felt like a very
difficult concept ever agreeing any kind
of increase because I knew what
residents were facing
then I thought about the fact that we
are supposed to be a representative
council and we cannot be a
representative
council if we are directly excluding
people who either through means or life
circumstances are not able to consider
taking up the responsibility of being a
counselor
so just to give you an idea LGA 2022
census recorded the following about
counselor
demographics 40% of councilors are
retired only 32% were in full or
part-time
employment 64% of counselors hold a
degree or equivalent or a higher
qualification only 4% hold no
qualification 59% of counselors are male
the average age of counselors in 2022
was 60 years years old only 16% were
aged under
45 and 42% of counselors were age 65 or
over young the system that we currently
have skews Democratic representation
based on income and age and independent
income we have to ensure that the
councilors that we have here are
representative of our actual population
and it can't be that in an area of
significantly High
deprivation that we don't consider
whether or not current allowances affect
whether or not people can enter the
world of politics thank
you right thank
you we have on the
list Pew right and manners is there
anybody else that wants to put the hand
up go be
so if you
just keep your hand up we'll get round
to
you right what well Nick's doing that
well Council few you're
onong thank you chair thank you um I'll
be honest there's quite a lot that I
agreed with uh counc R and with uh
councilor Whitehead and a lot of what
has already been said here uh tonight
it's right none of us do this for the
money nor should we anyone that
particularly with these allowances
that's trying to be a full-time
politician I tell you not to because you
know it's not the reason to do
it I think it's incredibly important and
Council Whitehead is spoken about this
about inclusivity and ensuring that
people who want to stand for public
office can and do but again I don't
think that it's the allowance that
convinces people that they want to do
that we all do this in this chamber
because we really care about making a
positive contribution and difference to
all of our residents lives it's as
simple as that I'm not going to be
political about that and say that only
the conservatives care because I don't
think any of us here would have stood
for office if we didn't believe that
what I do think is regrettable um is
that this proposal wasn't created on a
cross-party basis I understand the
reasons why it wasn't uh but I think
it's incredibly important to try and
find some consensus now that may be um
that the administration and the leader
knew that uh the conservative group and
others would never agree to a a oneoff
10% increase I certainly wouldn't and I
think um as councelor Davis has said you
can compare it to the increases that uh
some of our workers have seen because I
think it is in St contrast to that I
take exception to the report when it
includes uh the allowances for Kent
County Council and Medway uh Council as
well one's a unitary one's a County
Council I think it's entirely different
and I don't think that we can compare
their allowances to the district we may
be uh the lowest of members allowances
in Kent um but over the last 10 or so
years I think it's important subsequent
administrations not just conservative
administrations but administrations of
all parties and none um have agreed uh
by and large to not um accept or put
forward increases because of course it
should be us that is last on the list
when any budget or any proposals are
being put forward and it should always M
so I do support the proposal that
members allowances is linked to uh
officers increases I think that's
entirely fair and if that had been
brought uh to me and to the conservative
group prior to this coming to council we
would have supported that wholeheartedly
so I think it's really disappointing but
now is not the time for us to agree
whether it be a oneoff or not a oneoff
10% increase um and I won't be
supporting
it thank
you a call upon councelor brght
thank you
chair I can stay I can stay calm at this
time um i' I'd like to just reiterate a
lot of what council White had said and I
think this isn't about this is purely
about being socialist this is purely
about
allowing anyone sorry I'm not speaking
long enough this is purely about
allowing anyone to represent their
Community uh be they nurses care workers
teachers people on zero hours contracts
this is about people being out of pocket
most of us or many of us in this chamber
tonight are lucky enough that they can
take time out of their jobs they've got
the flexibility they need and they've
got the income they need they can afford
Child Care Etc but many people out there
can't and I think it's really important
that everyone gets is allowed to
represent the place that they live and
make decisions that impact on their
lives and other people's lives so I will
be supporting this motion thank you
I thank
you thank you chair
um I just find it a little bit
distasteful I suppose is the word I
would choose that um we should be
awarding ourselves or a pay Rise um
you can only spend a pound once and i'
ask my constituents the people in
cliftonville East where they would like
that pound spent um I was at the litter
Forum last week and was told that the
reason there had been no beach cleaning
and clifftop cleaning whatsoever since
September the 4th from botony Bay
Kingsgate along to Palm Bay was because
there was no money whatsoever to pay for
it um so several hundred hours of the
community's time as volunteers was spent
keeping our beaches and and Cliff tops
and streets clean because there was no
council provision now I would ask the
constituents in cliftonville East where
they would like that money spent either
additional allowances for counselors or
to keep beaches and and Cliff Toops
clean and I think they would choose not
to have to go out themselves as
volunteers unpaid that they would expect
the council to provide those Services
now I understand that the the some of
the arguments from uh across the room
that um about accessibility to local
politics for people um perhaps when
we've got our own finances in order and
we get a little bit better about
sweating our assets the assets that we
have the considerable property assets
that we have in thanet and we start
generating proper income from the
resources that we have then maybe that
would be a time to start spending money
but you can only spend a pound once and
and at the moment I think the priority
has to be on on what's going to benefit
the public thank you thank you councilor
maners a call on councelor
braywood yeah thank you chair
um yeah I have to agree with what
councelor Pew says uh councelor Davis
says uh councelor Manning says um I
don't think that now is the right time
to be increasing the members
allowance um
I do think it needs a review because
it's obviously been stagnant since 2015
but possibly review that in a year or
two years time I'm actually surprised
that some people in this chamber think
that they do deserve a members allowance
because a lot of the time they're
receiving money for doing absolutely
nothing um there's only a there's only a
very small minority of people in this
chamber there's only a very small
minority of people in this chamber that
are probably averaging pound an hour
doing casew work daytime weekend and
evenings he's very hard working very
hard working so yeah like I mentioned I
do think it needs a review at some point
in the future but but certainly not now
thank
you thank
you call upon councelor
Austin thank you chair I would like to
reflect what councelor Whitehead said I
also have was not inclined to support
this idea when I first heard about it
when I first heard about KCC councelors
voting themselves uh large increases in
allowances and so on I was horrified but
since then I have served as my par
election agent and I have had really
good potential candidates who've said
I'm sorry I can't afford to do that
because I'd have to give up some of my
paid work indeed some of my colleagues
in this group have lost considerable
amounts of paid work as a result of of
becoming counselors and indeed one of
them was in The Marvelous situation of
having to buy a car in order to be a
green counselor go figure how much that
has cost because it isn't possible
actually to get to all the meetings that
that person needed to get to by public
transport so these are the
considerations that we need to bear in
mind it's not as simple as it looks and
we are a really unrepresentative group
as it stands I personally as an early
retired person on a very modest income
find my counselor's allowance makes all
the difference and I know that's the
case with a few other people as well and
it would make it easier to attract
younger people people in Less well-paid
jobs Etc into the council so I support
this
motion thank you I call upon councilor
Kitman
yeah thank you um I wanted to firstly um
agree with councilor Whitehead um this
is about improving the opportunities we
hope for a my more diverse
representation of our population among
councilors um picking up also with what
councelor Austin has said um I'm able to
devote a lot more time to this role
because the allowance allows me to work
part-time I'm freelance um some of us
have that opportunity it's always
difficult to talk about your own pay
whatever it is and for the last 10 years
we've skirted around and we've gone no
no no we won't do it and every year the
recommendation has been actually you
ought to do it you ought to make a small
increase but for for 10 years we've gone
no and the only reason we're talking
about 10% now is because we've bulked at
making a decision in the past thank
you thank you call upon councelor
scobby thank you chair um it's
interesting to be in this this debate
again because uh when this was passed 10
years ago I think I was one of the
people that was pushing for it and it's
the same debate 10 years later um now
interesting thing I I completely agree
with what uh councelor Braidwood said
about some councelors maybe not doing
the work and judging by the amount of
case work that councelor Owen Hughes
councelor driver and I are picking up
that might be a reason why we are
elected and certain others are not um I
I definitely agree with some of the
comments um from across the chamber here
this is not a salary it is an allowance
uh and it is not necessarily a reason
why somebody would accept taking on the
role of a counselor but if this was not
there it could definitely be a deterrent
for people take it up I think we heard
from councelor Austin there if you're if
we are agreeing there has to be an
allowance in the first place to
encourage people from different
backgrounds to come into it then why
would we allow it to devalue over time
so that it makes it progressively harder
for people to engage in this process and
the 10% which I think people are fixing
on if you actually look at that in real
terms is very small but even if you look
at that 10% as CS over it said this on
the basis of nothing happening for 10
years and even before that small
increase 10 years ago nothing happening
for the 10 years before that so yet it
is a big one-off figure and there is now
a plan to index that to officers but
that's that's really sort of the
irrelevant Factor if we're accepting
there has to be an allowance to
encourage people then it is The Prudent
thing to do to make sure it's indexed
and is not reduced over
time thank you last one councilor Scott
please hello yeah I'll keep it quite
brief I mean I agree with my side with
our Council Pew and many of my other
colleagues have mentioned I mean I
became a counselor because I was
passionate I really wanted to get
involved with my community I mean I
joined a Town Council which is a
completely unpaid unallowed job um and I
treat it as a job um cuz I feel it's
professional and that's what a job is
you at professional you listen to your
residents who orbe it could be your
customers I just think when it comes to
saying things like um increasing it to
make it more approachable to diversify
um I mean as I see it I don't actually
see the current method anyone can apply
to be a counselor anyone with the drive
and the passion who cares can be a
counselor and I'm not sitting here on my
riches certainly I don't have riches I
take and pay cuts to treat this as a
full-time job so to say that you know to
assume that members in here because I
would never individually assume anyone
what they can afford what they can't
afford so to just come over and say or
maybe you can afford to be a counselor
no I can't but I do it because of the
passion and I do it because I care about
my actual Community I care about fet and
I care about my ward and I feel the same
for these and for anyone else and that's
why I'm not going to
you know vote in agreement with this I'm
going to refuse as well so thank
you I call on Council Everett to sum up
please yes thank you uh chair I won't go
on too much because I think we're all
anxious to get on and go out um but I
just to reply to a couple of points that
been made councelor Pew made the point
about the allowances in in meway and
Kent um well I've been a counselor in a
unitary Authority um and I can tell you
uh for nothing that nothing that there
there's no way that the workload in a
Authority is significantly greater than
the workload for District Council in
this Authority I think we demmin we
demean ourselves really if we seriously
believe that county councilors in Kent
are worth three and a half times what
our district councilors are wor there
are people in this Council who work far
harder than some um County counselors I
am certain and I'm not naming names or
identifying people but that's just going
to be the case so I don't think it's
unreasonable to include those and I say
to councelor manners because he he made
the point I think about what residents
in in clion Rel East would say well the
truth is that most residents will
probably think counselors shouldn't get
any allowance at all and they go a bit
further they probably think most Council
officers should have their pay cut and
work for nothing because they got that's
their opinion of them and I understand
that and I understand the Dynamics of
this debate and I understand why the
conservative group has to take up the
position that it does and unfortunately
that's why nothing has changed over the
last 10 years it's not been able to have
a sensible discussion because there's
never been a position that wasn't
political and couldn't be brought down
over a hung
Council that's why this labor group is
bringing forward I'm grateful to the
Cross party support from counc for
Rustin because this is an important
issue it needs to be resolved tonight
and then put to bed we shouldn't be
talking about our allowances with the
rest of this Council thank you right
thank
you it's been pointed out to me that you
did put your hand up C councilor bford
and if you would like to say something
that's you can go
ahead as the leader has said there is no
good time to raise allowances and I feel
that the present time could not be worse
when so many of our residents are
suffering financially I I feel this
sends a poor message to them I do not
think that 10% increase would enable
anyone wishing to be a counselor to do
so that could not do so now um I can I
cannot possibly support this increase
that would seem substantial to our
residents thank you thank
[Applause]
you we will go to a vote
then yes well
if we want over over half the people if
they want to have a recorded
vote do you want a recorded vote put
your hands
up so those those in favor of recorded
vote those in favor of recorded
[Music]
vote
those
against put your
there
the recording vote is
lost so by show of hands so right so
show of hands those in
favor 3 four five 6
s
okay and those
against yeah exensions any
extensions so ises anybody
one okay there's one over there
now you want again no no no I'm just
saying there there to too
big so that's a great that's agreed yeah
that's
agreed so that's agreed members
thank
you agenda item 15 funding the new
affordable homes I call upon councelor
Whitehead thank you chair and yes I am
noting that you're telling me to keep it
short Steve but it's just what it
is so previously in this chamber on the
13th of July I set out both our ambition
and our strategy to deliver over 400 new
affordable homes for rent over the
coming four years a huge increase on our
previous delivery rates our strategy is
based on mixed delivery including our
own high specification developments with
future plans for growth in Energy
Efficiency and delivery via unused
section 106 units which we risk losing
if we do not expand our model to include
them as councellors we have already
approved developments as part of this
strategy it began with the delivery of
42 Homes at at Spitfire green and now
continues with the potential acquisition
of 73 more homes to be discussed in
principle this
evening we have previously discussed the
strategy in totality with allocated
budgets totaling
28.35 million over 3 years and an
approved further budget for the first
two projects of the accelerated program
of 7.48 five
million our housing revenue account
business plan assumptions include
further tranches of funding for new
build 8.1 million in
2526 and 8.1 million in
2627 our strategy report projected that
the total cost of this accelerated
program would be between 90 and 100
million in total with 54 to 60 million
funded from Council borrowing and 36 to
40 million funded from external
sources details about the potential
sources of external funding were also
provided in the July
report the current currently approved
budget of
36051 million over four years is
allocated to existing projects already
agreed by cabinet which will deliver
between 123 and 128 homes of this amount
12.51 6 million is the 2324 approved
capital budget and is already committed
to existing projects further resources
over the Four Financial years from 2324
to
2627 will be required to complete the
program it is important to emphasize as
before that these are additional units
we are not in competition with housing
ass associations and do not want to be
we are simply determined to ensure that
any affordable housing created within
the planning system doesn't disappear
and is used to house our
residents if housing associations are
interested in different models of
delivery and are moving away from the
delivery of smaller numbers of units it
is important for us to adapt and include
these properties to maximize the
delivery of affordable housing inet
identifying this need and working to
include it within our strategy is
essential because the growth of our
housing portfolio directly enables
further growth via rent revenue and even
better provision for
residents offices have developed a
detailed viability assessment tool to
assess the viability of individual
schemes which is then used to inform a
go no-o decision for individual
proposals it is essential for the
viability of the overall program the
only schemes that have a positive impact
on the HRA business plan or general fund
are
delivered to be viable schemes need to
show an overall Surplus over a 30 or
50-year time scale depending on the
duration of any
borrowing the assessment tool operates
like a mini business plan and takes into
account all relevant costs and income
including rent income Capital costs
professional fees and project management
the cost of borrowing and management m
maintenance costs and depreciation over
the lifetime of the
homes although viable schemes show a
surplus over their lifetime cash flow in
the initial years is often in deficit it
is this cash flow deficit that acts as a
limiting factor in the scale of this
program each new project will be
reported to cabinet with details of its
impact on the housing revenue account
and the cash flow position over its
lifetime and only schemes that are
financially viable will be recommended
for approval
we have already approved the funding and
delivery of a further 47 homes on
identified sites as part of the ongoing
new bill program with construction due
to start early in
2024 there are further capital resources
available within the existing approved
HRA Capital program and a site
identified with capacity for around 20
homes however it is important to note
that this is dependent on external
funding for 40% of the cost which is yet
to be
secured in addition following following
the approval of the accelerated program
by Council in July 23 the council is in
negotiation for the acquisition of a
further 51 homes committing 7.48 five
million since July opportunities have
Arisen to occur a further tranch of new
homes in total 73 homes across five
sites the details of all these sites
will be presented to cabinet for
approval setting out details of the
costs and financial
viability this report recommends an
interim budget of 12 million to fun fund
these purchases details of the match
funding in the form of discounted
purchase values or grant funding will be
considered by cabinet when considering
each individual
project it is important to note that all
proposed sites will be fully reviewed as
each site has identified and
evaluated proposals for affordable and
sustainable developments come forward to
cabinet for app approval Capital budgets
will be reviewed as part of routine
budget setting and monitoring as these
programs progress so that Council can
approve the necessary funding at the
appropriate time this needs to be a
fully open and transparent process and
all checks and balances are in place to
enable this as may be obvious by now I
more than happy to field any questions
and answer any queries because this
needs to be a process that we are all
invested
in today council is asked to approve two
recommendations that we approve an
additional interim budget of 12 million
to the single Acquisitions and
development budget to continue
delivering the accelerated affordable
housing delivery pledge and to note that
detailed projects will continue to be
presented to the cabinet for approval as
they are
identified I am as always
extraordinarily proud of Housing and of
Finance for all the work that has gone
into supporting our commitment to
Residents housing needs the scale of
what has been achieved in a short period
of time is extraordinary and it is
Testament to the hard and often unseen
work the officers put into delivering
for
thanet we are heading into the fifth
month of this Administration ation using
previous averages we were producing
around eight properties across this
duration across the last 5 months we
have approved the detailed delivery of
homes to be fully clear about the impact
of this strategy if Council has support
these Acquisitions we will have
increased social housing delivery within
this Council by 500% in 5
months I am so proud of everyone in this
Council who has worked on this strategy
and extend thanks on of every one of the
1,64 households on our housing register
providing secure and affordable homes is
quite literally lifechanging for
residents and the difference that this
stands to make to our community is
extraordinary and I cannot thank you
enough I move the recommendations set
out in the
report can I have a second
please y
y thank you
thank you chair sorry I will I will be
quick I appreciate that probably some
people getting a bit tired um and it's
getting late um firstly I'd like to
thank councilor Whitehead for bringing
this forward I'm sure you've put a lot
of hard work into this along with the
housing team and the finance team so I
commend everyone for that firstly I'd
just like to say and I apologize chair
that this isn't technically related to
what this is but I the one enjoyed
hearing Council of white head speak even
though she went over her lot of time and
I'm not trying to make a point of that
but what I did notice was that everyone
was sitting here listening to what she
was saying and I'd like to make a point
that earlier unfortunately when I was
speaking and others were speaking they
were shouted down and shouted over when
they were trying to wrap up when they
went over their time so I'm hoping that
in general there can be a little bit
more leeway for all members who may
slightly go over the a lotted time
because I think Council whad uh made a
valuable contribution there and I don't
think it would have been in fair for her
to have cut off when the time
ended what I would say particularly
about uh this agenda item is that I'm
still quite concerned and make no
mistake very much support uh more
affordable housing uh across the
districts I think we have a real
shortage and it's something that uh all
residents are concerned about and of
course we need it we've got people on
the temporary uh temporary accommodation
and the housing register and everything
I completely understand that but I'm
still concerned about how all of this
will be funded I understand that in
general uh 54 to 60 million of it will
come from the council uh borrowing
itself uh particularly at a time when
rates are uh very high I don't think
that's particularly a wise decision but
we're also under the assumption that
we're going to be able to get external
funding of about 30 or 40 million uh
from elsewhere this district has just
been awarded £600,000 from central
government to try and help unlock um the
development of much needed homes for the
council and of course that's that's
great but £600,000 if it was added into
this is a drop in the ocean compared to
what we need to deliver um so I'm still
concerned about that I appreciate why
it's been brought forward and that we
need affordable housing across the
district but again I just think that
this is the potential for cost to spiral
out of control and as we know uh many
people when they see a local Authority
look into to uh purchase land or assets
um suddenly prices go up um and we're
seeing as a bit of a a piggy bank um but
thank you thank you councilor
PE
DAV councelor
Davis thank you chair I just want to
reiterate what my colleague councelor
Pew said and to express my concerns
regarding how this is going to be funded
because there's a lot of assumptions and
to quote an old uh or to quote an old
phrase uh to assume makes an ass of you
and me I don't think we should be
working on assumptions and I think we
have to be very very careful about
borrowing 40% of 100 million at current
interest rates um I
would uh recommend caution and possibly
looking at what we can build ourselves
instead of just keep going out to the
market because although I discussed this
with uh with officers before I don't
believe that the price per square foot
uh can't be bettered by providing
ourselves as opposed to going out to
third party developers so I've got a
value issue as well well as the um
speculative nature of the funding thank
you thank you call on councilor Everett
please um yeah thank you chair and um
when these sums of money are banded
around I sort of understand the caution
that that comes from opposition members
but I know that there's a huge amount of
work been done on the finances um behind
what's being proposed here I think we
have to recognize that um delivering
affordable homes and also ending the
temporary accommodation situation where
people are going out of areas which is
related to it um is the biggest priority
for this Council it is the most damaging
thing which is happening to our
residents but we would not be gambling
we would not be taking risks um and I
rely on um Mr blandel and Mr Porter uh
and the finance team for all the
expertise that they've put into putting
this policy together and I think off I
think you councilor Pew said what good
officers we had earlier I think you
should have some trust in them because
they wouldn't be bringing forward
proposals that were Reckless in terms of
the detail there will be an opportunity
to look at the finances behind each
individual set of purchases at cabinet I
think that's probably the place to do it
rather than here tonight in terms of the
overall budget but certainly we should
answer any questions that come forward
in that process I'm satisfied by it
they're Satisfied by it let's hope we
can satisfy you about the finances too
thank
you right members we are moving towards
10:30 Council of the 8S can you be brief
brief please I'll be very brief uh
Council Everett's just stolen my thunder
and said exactly what I was going to say
which is um each new project will come
to cabinet with cash flow forecasts so
let's look at the detail happy to be
scrutinized then um when there is the
detail so if you want affordable motions
please support if you want affordable
homes please support this tonight thank
[Applause]
you right do members agree
then
no you want to vote
vote so those in favor the motion
[Music]
then it's
lost
those
against and
then that's agreed
agenda item 16 review of outside bodies
24 I move the recommendation as set out
in the report be adopted would the vice
chair please second chair I agree do
members agree
AG item agenda item 17 changes to
committee I move that the
recommendations set out in the report
are adopted with the vice chair please
second seconded chair group leaders may
wish to take this opportunity to change
to their nominations to committees
panels and boards for remainder of 2023
24 Council EV do you wish to advise a n
changes no thank you
chair does he does he not want to change
his membership sorry do you want me to
do you want me to say it Nick's pointed
out to me do you want to change the
membership of the boundary location
party sorry CH I thought that was in the
report okay I'd like to replace
councelor will scobby from the
boundaries and elector Arrangements
working
party thank
you coun councilor Pew you want to
changes uh we have no changes chair
thank
you councilor
Garner no changes Council yo waro we
have no changes chair
right do members agree
agree concludes the business for the
meeting the council